ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE OF
MARCH TWENTY FIRST.
WE WILL.
START AS A SUB COMMITTEE
BECAUSE WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
FULL QUORUM.
ALSO CALL THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION THE HEARING TO ORDER
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
WILL HOLD OFF ON THE ROLE FOR
NOW.
UNTIL SUCH TIME AS A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED WE HAVE TWENTY
TWO BILLS ON FILE TODAY AND
SEVEN ARE ON CONSENT THE CONSENT
ITEMS ARE AS FOLLOWS. ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB NINETEEN SIXTY
TWO MISTER WHAT ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB TWO. TWO ZERO ZERO NINE MR
MAIENSCHEIN A BEING THAT.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWO ZERO
THREE ONE O'DONNELL.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHT MISTER WOULD ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN A BEACH TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY FIVE O'DONNELL ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN AB TWENTY THREE
ONE WAS BURKE. ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY THREE ZERO
FOUR THREE MISTER BERMAN.
FAMILIES FIFTEEN BILLS TO BE
HEARD SO WE HAVE A LONG DAY
TODAY.
WE'LL TAKE TESTIMONY FROM TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO EACH
MEASURE SO IT'S TO WITNESSES.
TWO MINUTES EACH WITH EACH
WITNESS TO AND TO REMEMBER THAT
PLEASE. EACH WISHED EACH WITNESS
AGAIN WILL HAVE TWO MODELS
COMING TO WITNESSES
ALL OTHERS AND SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION ARE WELCOME COME UP
TO THE MICROPHONE AND STATE GIVE
THEIR NAME. THEIR AFFILIATION
AND THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL
ONLY SO IF YOU COME UP THE MIKE
AFTER THE WITNESSES HAVE SPOKEN.
THAT IS NOT A TIME FOR FURTHER
DIATRIBE OTHER THAN WHETHER OR
NOT.
YOU SUPPORT THE BILL.
WITH THAT WE ARE READY FOR OUR
FIRST AUTHOR MISTER RODRIGUEZ I
BELIEVE IS PRESENT.
YOU MAY.
COME FORWARD WE WILL HEAR FROM.
ITEM NUMBER. TWO.
SEVENTEEN AB IF SEVENTEEN FORTY
SEVEN BY MISTER RODRIGUEZ AGAIN
THAT'S ITEM NUMBER TWO.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURRS.
I WANT TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS AS PROPOSED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
GUARANTEES CHILDREN THE RIGHT TO
ATTEND PUBLIC SCHOOLS WHICH ARE
SAFE SECURE AND PEACEFUL.
LAST YEAR ACCESS FOR A STATE
AUDIT OF SCHOOL SAFETY PLANS.
AND SURPRISINGLY.
IT WAS REVEALED THAT WE'RE
FALLING SHORT OF KEEPING OUR
STUDENTS SAFE.
THE AUDIT FOUND THAT MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DO NOT HAVE PROCEDURES
FOR RESPONDING TO VIOLENT
INCIDENTS SUCH AS ACTIVE
SHOOTERS.
BECAUSE IT IS NOT REQUIRED BY
LAW.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN
CODIFIES THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS AND WILL REQUIRE
SCHOOLS TO CREATE PROCEDURES TO
RESPOND TO VIOLENT INCIDENTS.
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT WOULD REQUIRE TO
CONSULT IN THE PLANNING AND
EVALUATION PROCESS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL WOULD
DIRECT APARTMENT EDUCATION TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE ON BEST
PRACTICES.
FOR SAFETY PLANS AND ASSURE
PLANS ARE REGULAR REGULARLY
UPDATED.
NOBODY WANTS TO THINK A WORLD
WHERE CHILDREN ARE NOT SAFE AT
SCHOOL BUT UNFORTUNATELY RECENT
INCIDENTS.
AND PARK LAND MARSHALL COUNTY
KENTUCKY AND RANCHO TEHAMA HAVE
SHOWN US THAT WE MUST BE
PREPARED FOR THE WORST.
WITH ME TODAY IS SUPERINTENDENT
OF THE CORNING UNION ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL DISTRICT RICH FITZPATRICK
TO TALK ABOUT THE RESPONSE TO
THE VIOLENT INCIDENTS THAT
OCCURRED. AND RAFTER TEHAMA
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL LAST YEAR
THANK YOU TWO MINUTES PLEASE ME
PROCEED.
THE SUPERINTENDENT FOR CORNING
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT
HAMMER COUNTY AND I'M GLAD TO BE
HERE TODAY.
ITS SIDE IT'S AN URGENT MATTER
ON NOVEMBER FOURTEENTH JUST A
LITTLE OVER FOUR MONTHS AGO AT
SEVEN FIFTY SIX IN THE MORNING
SHOOTER CAME ON THE CAMPUS OF
RANCHO TO HIM ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
INTENDING TO KILL AS MANY
STUDENTS AS POSSIBLE.
OUR SCHOOL SECRETARY HEARD A
GUNSHOT ABOUT.
FIVE HUNDRED YARDS UP THE ROAD
AND BY HER OWN DECISION CALL THE
LOCKDOWN.
FORTY FIVE SECONDS LATER OUR
ENTIRE CAMPUS WAS LOCKED DOWN
DOORS LOCK STUDENTS IN THE
CLASSROOMS.
TEN SECONDS LATER
A SHOOTER ARMED WITH HIGH CAP
MAGAZINES AND IN A OUR RIFLE
CAME INTO OUR QUAD AND FIRED
OVER A HUNDRED ROUNDS INTO OUR.
CLASSROOMS OFFICES AND WINDOWS
WE HAD ONE STUDENT INJURY WAS A
KINDERGARTEN WHO IS LAYING ON
THE FLOOR IN THE BACK OF THE
CLASSROOM HIDING UNDER A DESK.
WE HAD NO FATALITIES AND NO
OTHER WOUNDED STUDENTS.
THE REASON THAT IT HAPPENED IS
BECAUSE OUR DISTRICT AND OUR
SCHOOL AT THAT SITE HAD PREPARED
FOR LOCKDOWN PROCEDURES.
THEY WERE A REGULAR PART OF WHAT
WE DID.
AND THEY PERFORMED THEM.
PLEASE PLEASE.
AND PERFECTLY ADMIRABLY AND AS A
RESULT WE DON'T HAVE A BODY
COUNT.
ARE THEIR WOUNDS TO THE SCHOOL
STAFF YES ARE THEIR WOUNDS TO
OUR STUDENTS YES THEY HAVE TO
WALK THROUGH THE DAYS KNOWING
THAT.
THINGS ARE DIFFERENT AND THE
NORMAL THAT THEY KNEW MAY NEVER
COME BACK. BUT THEY'RE ALIVE TO
SEE IT.
THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER SUPERINTENDENT
I JUST WANTED KNOWLEDGE THAT.
YOU KNOW YOUR DISTRICT AT A
WONDERFUL JOB IN SUPPORTING THE
STUDENTS IN THE COMMUNITY
THROUGH THAT VERY TRAGIC AND
SCARY OF THAT.
I JUST.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MADISON
Y. ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN RED
CROSS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIELLE KENDO
KAISER ON BEHALF OF COMMON SENSE
KIDS ACTION IN SUPPORT.
BRENDA MARCHING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ANY ANY OPPOSITION ME WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
CLOSE.
IN CLOSING MEMBERS AND OUR
RESPONSIBILITY PROVIDE A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
STAFF AT OUR SCHOOLS ARE
STRICTLY OUT FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ AND
WE WILL HOLD OFF ON A MOTION
BECAUSE WE DO NOT THIS TO HAVE A
QUORUM. LIST WANTED NAUSEA YOUR
WORK ON THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT.
I'M MY OWN SCHOOL DISTRICT I
KNOW WE'VE BEEN THROUGH THOSE
DRILLS BUT THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH CREATING A STATEWIDE
PROTOCOL AND EXPECTATION.
THAT EVERY SCHOOL.
IS WELL VERSED IN LOCKDOWNS
SHOULD INCIDENTS LIKE THIS OCCUR
NEAR THEM.
I'VE BEEN THROUGH MANY LOCKDOWN
AND MANY A PRACTICE OF A
LOCKDOWN BUT AGAIN INSURING THAT
ALL SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
DOING. IS IS IS IS IMPORTANT SO
THANK YOU VERY COMMENTS FOR ANY
OTHER COMMITTEE. SO WITH THAT
WILL HOLD UP TO WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM FOR OUR MOTION.
AND THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING
THANK YOU.
AND NEW I HAVE.
IN ADDITION YOU HAVE.
.
THE SEA AB I DID FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE A. B. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY ONE YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS A BEAT
EIGHTEEN SIXTY ONE REQUIRE
SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE EDUCATION TO
STUDENTS ON HOW SOCIAL MEDIA AND
MOBILE PHONE DEVICES ARE USED TO
GROOM. AND LOWER YOUTH TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
UNFORTUNATELY AND ESTIMATED
THREE HUNDRED CHILDREN ARE
AFFECTED. FOR COMMERCIAL SEX AND
FORCED LABOR EVERY YEAR.
TRAFFICKERS ARE QUICKLY ADAPTING
TO NEW AGE MEDIA SOCIAL MANY
OUTLETS LIKE FACEBOOK INSTAGRAM
ALLOWED TRAFFICKERS.
DO CONTACT KIDS WHO THEY FEEL
ARE MOST VULNERABLE.
MOBILE MOBILE PHONE DEVICE
APPLICATION SUCH A SNAPSHOT
ALLOWED TRAFFICKERS
TO LEAVE NO TRACE
CHAD HISTORIES ARE AUTOMATICALLY
DELETED. WHEN ONE LOGS OUT
DELETE THE APP OR THE COUNT IS
DEACTIVATED. FOR THESE REASONS
AND MANY MORE PREVENTIVE
MEASURES MUST BE TAKEN AND THE
START WITH EDUCATION OUR
CHILDREN.
LAST YEAR LEGISLATION REQUIRED
HUMAN TRAFFICKING PREVENTION.
EDUCATION TO BE PROVIDED TO
STUDENTS IN GRADES SEVEN THROUGH
TWELVE. THIS BILL SIMPLY
CLARIFIES THE USE OF SOCIAL
MEDIA AND MOBILE PHONE
APPLICATIONS TO BE INCLUDED IN
EDUCATION PROVIDED TO THE
STUDENTS.
TODAY I'M JOINED BY THE ADVOCATE
FROM FAMILY SYSTEM OPEN DOOR
PROGRAM WHO WORKS WITH SURVIVORS
EVERYDAY. AND COOPER FROM THE
CITY MANAGER POLICE DEPARTMENT
WHO WORKS FOR THE SOMEBODY NO
HUMAN TRIP TRAFFICKING TASK
FORCE.
DOES FIND SUPPORT.
YOUR WITNESS MAY PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AMBER'S THANK YOU FOR HAVING
TODAY.
MY NAME IS EMILY DICKSON AND I
AM A SURVIVOR ADVOCATE. FOR
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
INSANITY NO COUNTY.
TODAY I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF OPEN
DOOR PROGRAM A. NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT HELPS
SURVIVORS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTEEN SIXTY ONE DUE TO
THE FACT THAT WITHIN THE LAST
THREE YEARS WE HAVE HAD CLIENTS
COME THROUGH OUR PROGRAM WHO
WERE RECRUITED ONLINE.
OUR CLIENTS DISCLOSE THAT SOCIAL
MEDIA SITES HAVE PLAYED A MAJOR
ROLE IN THE GROOMING AND
RECRUITMENT OF VICTIMS.
WE LEARNED THAT SOME VICTIMS
WERE BEFRIENDED BY TRAFFICKERS
WHO AT FIRST POSE AS A FRIEND
WHO WAS ATTRACTED TO THE VICTIM
AND WANTED TO BUILD SOME KIND OF
ROMANTIC RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM.
THE TRAFFICKERS WOULD HAVE
INTIMATE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THEIR VICTIMS TO FIND OUT ALL
VULNERABILITIES DISLIKES AND
WANTS IN ORDER TO PREY ON THEM.
AT THE BEACH VICTIMS WEAKEST
MOMENT THE TRAFFICKER WOULD
POUNCE AT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THEMSELVES AS A SAVIOR
AND OR A RESCUER. ONLY DISSECT
THEM INTO A LIFESTYLE OF
EXPLOITATION AND MEANS OF
SURVIVAL.
IN ADDITION TO ONLINE
RECRUITMENT BY TRAFFICKERS
THEMSELVES WE HAVE ALSO WORKED
WITH VICTIMS WHO WERE RECRUITED
ONLINE BY OTHER HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS. WHO ARE
ALSO KNOWN AS THE BOTTOM?
THE BOTTOM WILL BE FROM THE
TRAFFICKERS NEXT POTENTIAL
VICTIM AND FLASH PICTURES THE
MONEY MATERIALISTIC ITEMS SUCH
AS HIGH AND PURSES CARS CLOTHING
ETCETERA.
ONCE THE VICTIM SHOWS INTEREST
THE BOTTOM WILL CONTINUE TO
INITIATE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
VICTIM TO GLAMORIZING GLORIFY
THE LIFE AND MAKE PROMISES TO
THE VICTIM THAT HE OR SHE WILL
BE ABLE TO HAVE THOSE SAME
ITEMS.
IN THE VICTIM'S WEAKEST MOMENT
THE TRAFFICKER WILL HAVE HIS OR
HER BOTTOM JUMP ON THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACT AS THE SAVIOR
RESCUER TO THE VICTIM. AND THEN
INTRODUCE THEM TO A LIFE OF
HUMAN SEX TRAFFICKING AND
EXPLOITATION.
FOR THOSE FOR THESE REASONS WE
ASK THAT A. B. EIGHTEEN SIXTY
ONE GET PAST EDUCATING YOUTH ON
THE DANGERS OF SOCIAL MEDIA AND
MOBILE PHONE DEVICES IS VITAL
WHEN TEACHING ABOUT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. PREVENTIVE MEASURES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU UNDER TWO MINUTES WELL
DONE YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
YOUR CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME TODAY.
MY NAME IS NICK LEFFLER I'M A
CORPORAL WITH THE CITY OF
ONTARIO POLICE DEPARTMENT. I'M
HERE TODAY REPRESENTING THE SAN
MARINO COUNTY HUMAN TRAFFICKING
TASK FORCE.
LARGELY OUR SOCIETIES UNAWARE OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND THE SUB
CULTURE OF COMMERCIALIZED SEX
FOR SALE BUT AS PRESIDENT AND
COMMUNITIES ACROSS OUR STATE.
SINCE MAY TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
OUR TASK FORCES RESCUED FORTY
NINE ADULTS AND TWENTY FIVE
JUVENILES DURING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING INVESTIGATION.
WE HAVE FOUND JUVENILE VICTIMS
THIRTEEN YEARS OF AGE AND
YOUNGER.
DURING THESE INVESTIGATIONS WE
HAVE FOUND THAT THE PRIMARY
RECRUITING GROUND FOR JUVENILES
IS ON THE INTERNET THROUGH
SOCIAL MEDIA.
SOCIAL MEDIA PROVIDES A PLATFORM
FOR TRAFFICKERS TO BEFRIEND
BEFRIEND MINERS INITIATE SECRET
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEM ENGAGE
IN PRIVATE CONVERSATIONS.
AND EVENTUALLY BEGIN TO
MANIPULATE THEM INTO WORKING FOR
THEM AS COMMERCIAL SEX WORKERS.
I WANT TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE TWO EXAMPLES TO PUT
INTO CONTEXT WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
AFTER WORKING HUMAN TRAFFICKING
INVESTIGATIONS FOR JUST A SHORT
TIME.
IT WAS EVIDENT TO ME THAT
TRAFFICKERS RECRUITING THEIR
VICTIMS THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA.
TO COMBAT THIS TYPE OF CRIME AND
PRO ACTIVELY SEEK OUT THE
TRAFFICKERS I DECIDED TO CREATE
A SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNT. POSING
AS A FIFTEEN YEAR OLD FEMALE
GIRL.
DURING THE FIRST FULL DAY OF
MAINTAIN THIS ACCOUNT I'D
RECEIVED NUMEROUS FROM REQUESTED
OVER FIFTY MESSAGES FROM
TRAFFICKERS WHO WERE ATTEMPTING
TO BEGIN RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THIS FICTITIOUS CHILD.
I'VE SINCE ARRESTED SEVERAL OF
THOSE PREDATORS FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING BASED ON THEIR
CONVERSATIONS WITH ME IN THAT
UNDERCOVER ROLE.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THE
CONNECTION CONNECTION BETWEEN
SOCIAL MEDIA AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS THIS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
DECEMBER DANIELLE TASK FORCE
BEGAN AN INVESTIGATION WHICH LED
TO THE ARREST OF THE SUSPECTED
CAMP IN THE CITY OF ONTARIO.
DURING THE INVESTIGATION WE
LEARN THAT THE SUSPECTED
CAMPAIGN USE SOCIAL MEDIA TO
ATTEMPT TO BEFRIEND AND RECRUIT
AT LEAST FIVE RANDOM FEMALES PER
DAY.
IS IMPORTANT WE EDUCATE OUR
CHILDREN ABOUT THE ABOUT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND HIDDEN DANGERS
THAT EXIST IN THE REALM OF
SOCIAL MEDIA SO THEY CAN GUARD
THEMSELVES AGAINST BECOMING THE
NEXT VICTIM.
DECEMBER YOU KNOW COUNTY HUMAN
TRAFFICKING TASK FORCES IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION AND SO.
THOSE ARE A GOMEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE OPEN DOOR PROGRA IN THE
CITY OF SUNBURN DINO IN FULL
SUPPORT.
DANIELLE KENDO KAISER ON BEHALF
OF COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT WE'VE AWARDED
THIS BILL ARE STAR RATINGS YOU.
BRAVER NOW THE CATHOLIC CHURCH
CALIFORNIA WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. BUT YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ISABEL
GARCIA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
WERE PROJECT RECOMMEND A FORMAL
SUPPORTED ARE A FIRST COUNTS OF
EDUCATION MEETING THANK YOU.
KATHY HALL THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PARENT TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO OPPOSITION WE CANNOT
GO MOTION OF THIS TIME YOU MAKE
CLOSE.
WITHOUT.
CHAIR RESPECT US FOR OUR VOTE ON
THE SUPPORT VERY POINT MEASURE
THANK YOU.
I NEXT WE HAVE AS MISTER
SANTIAGO.
PRESIDENT.
WHERE?
OTHERS.
GET OFF YOUR SOCIAL MEDIA GET UP
HERE.
YES CAN.
OKAY SO ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY ONE.
WHICH IS AB THREE ZERO FOUR TWO.
THINGS ARE CHAIR OF WOULD IT BE
OKAY WITH A CHAIR BECAUSE BRIEF.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU FOR LIKE A
SUBCOMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS
AMENDED AB THREE.
THIRTY FORTY TWO WHILE WOULD
PROVIDE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE
OPPORTUNITY COMBINE TO PRESENT
DAY HOLIDAYS. I IN THE ONE AND
DESIGNATE MAY FIRST AS HOLIDAY
KNOWN AS THE INTERNATIONAL
WORKERS DAY.
TWO WITNESSES WHO ALSO BE BRIEF
THINK MISTER THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
IS OF THE COMMITTEE RON RAP ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE
PROUD SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON IT.
AYE MANY YIELD MY TIME TO OUR
MAIN WITNESS FRED CLAUS FRED IS
THE AUTHOR OF MISSION TO
MICROCHIP HISTORY OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR MOVEMENT. HE'S
ALSO AN ADJUNCT PROFESSOR UC.
CITY COLLEGES SAN FRANCISCO HE
TEACHES LABOR HISTORY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
WHICH OF THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE HAS MISTER WRAPS AT MY
NAME IS FRED CLASS THANKS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SAY A FEW
WORDS ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
MAY FIRST AS A WORKERS HOLIDAY.
AND WHY SHOULD WE SHOULD ADOPTED
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE HOLIDAY SHOULD BE UNDERSTOOD
AS BELONGING TO EVERY WORKER
EVERYWHERE IT CELEBRATES THE
BIRTH OF THE MOVEMENT FOR THE
EIGHT HOUR WORKDAY A SEEMINGLY
IMPOSSIBLE GOAL. AT A TIME IN
THE NINETEENTH CENTURY WHEN TEN
EVEN TWELVE HOUR DAYS WERE
COMMON SIX AND SOMETIMES SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK.
HE WOULD WRITE AN HISTORIC
INJUSTICE FOR THE HOLIDAY TO
FINALLY BE CELEBRATED OFFICIALLY
SOMEWHERE IN UNITED STATES.
THAT'S BECAUSE THIS COUNTRY IS
WHERE THE EVEN SICKERT STRIKES
AND DEMONSTRATIONS BY A LARGELY
IMMIGRANT WORKFORCE IN THE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTIES THAT BEGAN THE
MOVEMENT FOR THE EIGHT HOUR DAY
WHICH WAS ONLY CROWNED WITH
SUCCESS FIFTY YEARS LATER.
THE PASSAGE OF THE FAIR LABOR
STANDARDS ACT.
HELPING STUDENTS UNDERSTAND
WHERE THEIR BASIC WORKPLACE
RIGHTS COME FROM IS CRUCIAL TO
PROTECTING THEM TODAY AND IN THE
FUTURE.
THESE RIGHTS WERE HARD WON OFTEN
AT THE COST OF WORKERS JOBS.
BLOOD IN LIVES.
IT'S NOT A COINCIDENCE THAT THE
NATIONAL LABOR RELATIONS ACT
PROVIDING PEACEFUL CONFLICT
RESOLUTION IN THE WORKPLACE
THROUGH COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
WAS PASSED IN NINETEEN THIRTY
FIVE A YEAR AFTER A WAVE OF
GENERAL STRIKES WITNESSED
INJURIES TO HUNDREDS. AND IN
SOME PLACES THOUSANDS OF WORKERS
AND THE DEATHS
BUT DOZENS.
I MADE A HOLIDAY INAPPROPRIATE
LABOR HISTORY EDUCATIONAL
EXERCISE OF SURROUNDING IT WOULD
PROVIDE STUDENTS MANY OF WHOM
ALREADY WORK WITH AN
APPRECIATION FOR WHAT IT TOOK TO
CREATE WORKPLACE RIGHTS AND WHAT
THEY STAND TO LOSE IF THOSE
RIGHTS ARE LIMITED. IN SHORT THE
MERIT OF THE HOLIDAY THE MERITS
OF THE HOLIDAY FIT CLOSELY WITH
WHAT CALIFORNIA STANDS FOR TODAY
AS AN ISLAND OF SANITY UNDER THE
CURRENT FEDERAL POLITICAL AND
POLICY ENVIRONMENT.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB THIRTY FORTY TWO.
WE THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CITY
WHATEVER.
I AM THE PACIFICA PART OF
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE
CHAIR WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IT'S BEEN PUT IN A
PLATFORM FOR A LONG TIME. THANK
YOU.
MANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY PLEASE
MY NAME IS JOHN RIEGER AND
SECRETARY OF THE. PEACE AND
FREEDOM PARTY STATE CENTRAL
COMMITTEE AND URGING YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT BILL
GREAT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DEREK CLINICS BEYOND ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT SEEN
OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY IN
OPPOSITION.
YOU MAY CLOSE EYES WERE CLARIFY
THAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
OLD YOU DO HAVE OKAY. SO I
CLARIFY WE ARE TALKING ON THE
AMENDED VERSION WHICH IS
PERMISSIVE IN THAT DISTRICTS CAN
CHOOSE THE CURRENT MODEL.
TO PRESIDENT HOLIDAYS OR IF THEY
SO CHOOSE THEY MAY MOVE TO THE
US SUGGESTED MOM
THE ONE THAT HAS BEEN
SENATE HERE TODAY AGAIN THIS
BILL IS NOW.
BEING AMENDED TO BE PERMISSIVE
WITH THAT MISTER KILEY AND I DO
THINK THAT'S A GOOD AMENDMENTS.
THOUGHT THAT THE COMMITTEE FOR
SUGGESTING THEM OF THE AUTHOR
FOR TAKING THEM I'M STILL
CURIOUS I MEAN WE ONLY HAVE A
LABOR DAY.
HOW WHY DO WE NEED TO KINDA? I
KNOW JUST SIDE PRESIDENT LINCOLN
OR PRESIDENT WASHINGTON ORDERED
CREATE THIS OTHER INTERNATIONAL
WORKERS I'M GLAD YOU ASKED.
I KNEW YOU WOULD.
MY THAT PREDICT THE MOST.
YES.
LABOR DAY SO THE CELEBRATE THE
SOCIAL ECONOMIC ACHIEVEMENT OF
AMERICAN WORKERS.
DE OUR INTERNATIONAL WORKERS
DAY.
IT STARTS OFF THAT'S ABOUT ALL
ALL WORKERS ACROSS THE WORLD.
GO WORKERS
ALRIGHT.
DID YOU WISH CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOAT.
THANK YOU ON WILL I MAKE A
MOTION THIS TIME BECAUSE WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM THAT WILL MOVE
AS.
WE DO HAVE A.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WILL MOVE ON
TO US MR MEDINA PRESENT.
AREAS.
AND IT'S ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN.
EIGHTEEN WHICH IS AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY TWO.
IN THE MAIN.
PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
TODAY I PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TWO.
A BILL THAT WILL ADD A COURSE OF
ETHNIC STUDIES.
TO BE A HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT.
BEGINNING THIS SCHOOL YEAR
TWENTY. TWENTY THREE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR.
AND.
BEFORE GOING ON ANY FURTHER
WANNA SAY THAT I ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS.
AND TO THE CHAIR AND THE STAFF
WANTED THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
HARD WORK.
AND.
AND THANK YOU.
AND AGAIN.
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS THAT
IS SUGGESTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
ON MONDAY OF THIS WEEK.
WE RECOGNIZED
STUDENTS.
WHO FIFTY YEARS AGO?
WALKED OUT OF.
HE'S STILL A HIGH SCHOOLS.
A.
WITH CERTAIN DEMANDS.
DEMANDS THAT THEIR TEACHERS LOOK
LIKE THEM.
THAT THEY HAVE COUNSELORS.
WHO?
LOOK LIKE THEM.
THAT THERE WOULD BE CURRICULA.
IN THE BOOKS IN THE TEXTBOOKS.
THAT REFLECTED.
THEIR HISTORY THEIR CULTURE.
AND I AM REFERRING TO THE EAST
LA. A STUDENT WALKOUTS OF
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT.
AS A LONGTIME HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER.
OF SOCIAL STUDIES.
TEACHING U. S. HISTORY AND WORLD
HISTORY.
A HAVING TAUGHT.
AMERICAN GOVERNMENT AND
ECONOMICS.
AND ALSO BEING A.
.
K. TWELVE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
TEACHER.
THERE IS A HUGE GAP.
IN THE CURRICULUM TODAY.
AND WHAT STUDENTS ARE TAUGHT.
AND IF WE LOOK. INTO OUR US
HISTORY BOOKS.
THE US HISTORY BOOK THAT IS
TAUGHT IN JUNIOR YEAR HISTORY.
YOU WILL NOT SEE.
A WHOLE LOT.
UNLIKE THE YOU KNOW. CULTURE
HISTORY.
YOU WILL NOT SEE A WHOLE LOT.
AFRICAN AMERICAN.
CULTURE AND HISTORY.
YOU WILL NOT SEE A LOT ON ASIAN
AMERICAN. OR NATIVE AMERICAN
HISTORY.
I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY AT
RIVERSIDE UNIFIED.
I TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES AND
CHICANO STUDIES FOR SEVERAL
YEARS.
AND I'VE FOUND THAT THE STUDENTS
THAT I TAUGHT.
IN BOTH OF THOSE CLASSES
ETHNIC STUDIES AND UGANDA
STUDIES.
VERY MUCH VALUED WHAT THEY
LEARNED IN MY CLASSROOM SO MUCH
SO. THAT WHEN THEY SEE ME TODAY.
THEY MAKE IT A POINT TO GO OUT
OF THEIR WAY.
THANK ME
FOR WHAT THEY LEARNED IN THEIR
CLASSROOM.
IN THAT IN THOSE CLASSES.
SO I VERY MUCH IN PRESENTING
THIS BILL.
I THINK IT'S PAST TIME THAT WE
INCLUDE.
HISTORY.
CULTURE THE LITERATURE.
OF ALL ETHNIC GROUPS
TO OUR SOCIAL TO OUR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
AND SO THAT IS WHY I'M BUILDING
UPON. THE WORK OF MISTER ALEJO.
AND THE.
BILL THAT HE GOT PASSED AND
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR.
AND.
PREPARING.
OF THE CURRICULUM NOW.
IT BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
TO.
MAKE IT SO THAT EVERY HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATE.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WOULD.
HAVE TO TAKE
A CLASS
SO MASTER CLASS
IN ETHNIC STUDIES
FOR GRADUATION.
AS I LOOK BACK AND THINK OF WHAT
IT IS IT MEAN TO BE EDUCATED.
THIS STATE AND IN THIS NATION.
I DON'T THINK THAT YOU CAN CLAIM
TO BE AN EDUCATED PERSON.
IN OUR SOCIETY TODAY IF YOU DO
NOT KNOW THE HISTORY.
CULTURE OF ALL GROUPS OF WHICH
ARE REPRESENTED IN THIS STATE
AND IN THIS NATION.
SO WITH THAT I'M VERY PROUD TO
BRING THIS BILL FORWARD.
AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
WITH ME HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TWO.
IS DR DALE ALLENDER PROFESSOR OF
AT SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY.
AND MY GOD IT THE BEST THAT
POPULAR.
WHO WILL SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THIS
BILL?
THANK YOU MAY PROCEED REMAINING.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR MEDHI BABETTE
BABBY LA I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF
ETHNIC STUDIES NOW STATEWIDE
COALITION. AS WELL AS ETHNIC
STUDIES NOW SACRAMENTO. I'M ALSO
PROFESSOR OF EDUCATION AT
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY.
I PREPARE STUDENTS WHO WANT TO
ENTER THE FIELD AS FUTURE HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHERS.
SPECIFICALLY IN ETHNIC STUDIES.
I AM HERE TODAY TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY TWO. I'M NOT SHARED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA IT'S BEEN
FIFTEEN YEARS SINCE NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT AND CURRENTLY. WE
ARE STILL WORKING AND ORGANIZING
AND NEW LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS IN CITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA ARE PASSING
RESOLUTIONS.
REQUIRING ETHNIC STUDIES
CLASSES.
AT THE URGENCY OF ITS MOST
IMPORTANT CONSTITUENTS
STUDENTS PARENTS AND TEACHERS.
HELP GROVE JUST LAST NIGHT HELD
A BOARD MEETING IN WHICH
HUNDREDS OF OR MANY STUDENTS
TEACHERS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
PUT FORTH THEIR REQUEST TO HAVE
ETHNIC STUDIES. AT ELK GROVE
UNIFIED BECAUSE OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT HAVE BEEN
PLAGUING OUR GROVE.
IN ADDITION WE HAVE THE PASSING
AS MENTIONED AB TWENTY SIXTEEN.
WHICH IS THE DEVELOPMENT OF
ETHNIC STUDIES MODEL CURRICULUM
SO AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY TWO
COMES AT AN OPPORTUNE TIME. WHEN
GROWING RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES A
POWERFUL RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULUM AND
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT. MOREOVER
IT AFFIRMS WHAT WE KNOW FOR
DECADES
CURRICULUM AND INSTRUCTION IN
CLASSROOM WHICH ENGAGES STUDENTS
AND STUDENTS OF COLOR
SPECIFICALLY.
WELL AS WHAT LEASE ADOPTED STEPS
THEIR INTELLECTUAL LEGACY
CLARIFYING THEIR POSITION. IN A
RACIALIZED SOCIETY.
RITUALLY EXPRESSES EXPECTATIONS
FOR HARD WORK AND ACADEMIC
SOCIAL PHYSICAL AND MORAL
EXCELLENCE.
HAS ONE FOR COMMUNITY FOR ONE'S
ANCESTORS AND FOR ONCE
DESCENDANTS MATERIALIZE ASTUTE
INDIVIDUALS.
CONSCIOUSLY POLITICALLY AND
ACADEMICALLY.
MORE SPECIFICALLY AS CHRIS
LEADERS REVIEW OF LITERATURE
STATES ARE SHARES REGARDING
ETHNIC STUDIES IT OFFERS
STUDENTS THE OPPORTUNITY PLEASE
SUMMERS.
I THINK YOU IT OFFERS
OPPORTUNITY UP.
OFFER STUDENTS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ENGAGE WITH OUR COMMUNITY
CREATIVE INTELLECTUAL PRODUCTS
BOTH HISTORICALLY IN
CONTEMPORARY.
LASTLY I WOULD LIKE QUICKLY TO
SUMMARIZE PLEASE THANK YOU. IN
LIGHT OF THE MOVEMENT OCCURRING
ACROSS THE STATE IN MOVING
ETHNIC STUDIES FORWARD IN HIGH
SCHOOLS AND WHAT THE RICHER
STATES THE TIME HAS COME FOR THE
LATTER TO BE AFFIRMED AND SAM
SHAKE YOU.
GOOD JOB.
NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBERS MY NAME
IS DR DALE ALLENDER HAS STATED
AT.
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY AND
COLLEGE OF EDUCATION HERE TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THIS BILL.
ARE ALSO REPRESENTING ETHNIC
STUDIES NOW SACRAMENTO.
I HAVE A UNIQUE ROLE IN THAT.
ORGANIZATION AND THAT I
PRIMARILY WORK ON THE DEVELOPING
OF CURRICULUM AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR. TEACHERS IN
THIS CITY IN THIS REGION AND
ALSO THROUGHOUT THE STATE. HOW
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I CAN
SHARE WITH YOU IS THAT AND
DEVELOPING? THE FIRST ETHNIC
STUDIES HIGH SCHOOL TEXTBOOK.
.
WE'VE GONE BACK TO ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINTH GRADERS
TO LOOK AT THAT BOOK AND TALK TO
US ABOUT IMPROVEMENTS FOR FUTURE
EDITIONS OF IT.
WE ASK THEM WHAT THEY LIKE WHAT
THEY DON'T LIKE AND WHAT THEY
WOULD CHANGE AND THE THE THING
THAT THEY SAY THAT THEY LIKE.
ALMOST ACROSS THE BOARD ALL ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY OF THEM SAID THEY
REALLY LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN ABOUT THEMSELVES. AND TO
LEARN ABOUT OTHERS IN THEIR
COMMUNITY AND THAT THE MATERIALS
IN THE COURSE HELP THEM DO THAT.
I WANT TO JUST REITERATE THE
IMPORTANCE THAT THE RESEARCH
STATES THAT THERE IS ACADEMIC
AND SOCIAL VALUE IN ETHNIC
STUDIES COURSES. IN THAT
ACADEMIC VALUE IS DESCRIBED AS
INCREASED GRADES INCREASED TEST
SCORES INCREASED OUR GRADUATION
RATES.
DECREASED TRUANCY AND DECREASED
DROP OUT RATE NO STUDIES ARE
BOTH QUALITATIVE AND
QUANTITATIVE.
AS WAS VERY IMPORTANT WE TAKE
NOTE OF THAT LAST THING I WANT
TO SAY IS THAT IT'S CLEAR
NUMBERS YES SIR. ARE THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AT THE RESEARCH ALSO
THAT THAT WE HIGHLIGHT IN THE
RESEARCH ALSO THE VERY SPECIFIC
APPROACHES THAT WILL YIELD THOSE
ACTIVITIES IN A PROFESSIONAL DEL
YOU PRESENT THANK YOU SIR.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY PLEASE
DOCTOR ROBERT MCAULIFFE
RODRIGUEZ PROFESSOR OF ETHNIC
STUDIES SPECIFICALLY ASIAN
AMERICAN STUDIES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS.
AND NATIONAL BOARD MEMBER FOR
THE ASSOCIATION FOR ASIAN
AMERICAN STUDIES AND FULL
SUPPORT.
SANTIAGO LET US STAY PRESIDENT
CAFE THE CALIFORNIA CHICANO
LATINO.
ASSOCIATION AND.
BOARD MEMBER UC DAVIS ALUMNI
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
TONY PEREZ REPRESENTING MYSELF
AS A. AS A MEMBER OF THE ELK
GROVE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
FIFTH LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA.
SUPPORT.
CARLOS OUT ALONE CHAIR OF THE
CHICANO LATINO CAUCUS.
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
RECOMMEND SUPPORT.
NORMAL CALL I'M PRESIDENT FOR
WASHINGTON UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHERE SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPRT WE ALSO PASSEDA
RESOLUTION UNANIMOUSLY PEGGY.
OVERALL A TORY HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
DANIELLE CAN A KAISER ON BEHALF
OF COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IN
SUPPORT.
ERIC HARRIS CALIFORNIA STATE
NAACP IN SUPPORT.
THERE CLINICS ON BEHALF OF SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND SPORTS.
FREDERICK GROW METAL.
US MARINE.
SHE GOT A VIETNAM VETERAN.
STATE COMMANDER OF THE AMERICAN
GI FORUM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
MARTHA SARAGOSSA DEUS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATION AND CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND OUR LETTER OF SUPPORT
THIS FOURTH COME.
THANK YOU.
TOMMY TINKER BLACK PARA ALSO
BOARD AND CENTER FOR AFRICAN
PEACE AND CONFLICT RESOLUTION
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
IT'S ABOUT GARCIA CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE DO NOT
HAVE A FORMAL POSITION BUT WE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS IMPORTANT BILL AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE DISCUSSING THE
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT AT OUR
STATE CONSTITUTION MEETING. SO
IT'S LIKE THE BILL TO KEEP
MOVING FORWARD.
BOBBI ROWING NATIONAL TRUSTEE
FOR THE PHILIPPINE AMERICAN
NATIONAL STARK A SOCIETY IN
SUPPORT.
MY LETTER MEDI CAL THOUGH.
CULTURAL STUDIES PHD STUDENT AT
UC DAVIS AND IN FULL SUPPORT.
FRED JONES ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR THE SOCIAL STUDIES
JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN AND THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING OUT THE AMENDMENTS TO.
PROTECT SOME OF THE ELECTIVE
HISTORY SOCIAL SCIENCE COURSES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
SENIOR TO SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THAT WE
OUGHT TO SAY THIS INCLUDES THE
IRISH RIGHT THE DOES. SAN
ANDREAS HEROES YOU KNOW THEY
ABOUT CO BRIGADE RIGHT.
MISTER KILEY HAVE THAT SAME
QUESTION I THINK ACTUALLY.
I WAS A CO ANY QUESTIONS.
NOW.
I AGREE WITH THAT.
YOU MAY CLOSE PLEASE.
I.
DIDN'T SAY IN MY OPENING AND I
DO WANNA SAY IN THE CLOTHES THAT
IT WAS GREAT WHAT WE DID ON THE
FLOOR THE ASSEMBLY ON MONDAY.
TO RECOGNIZE THOSE STUDENTS.
BUT IF WE DON'T GIVE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY.
TO TO LEARN ABOUT THEIR PAST ARE
PASSED.
OF WE HAVEN'T DONE OUR JOB.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT WE THERE'LL BE NO
MOTION AS OF.
TILL WE GET THAT WARM BUT THANK
YOU OVER THAT AYE MR AYE VOEPEL
IS HERE BELIEVE.
THAT'S ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN.
YOU.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
THAT'S GOOD.
THE CHAIRMAN.
MY COMMITTEE SISTERS AND
BROTHERS.
GOT SOME A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
HERE FAR YOU.
TODAY AYE PRESENT A. B. TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT THAT IS AN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTY ONE
SPECIFIC BILL. ASKING THAT THE
CAJON VALLEY UNION SCHOOL
DISTRICT GROSSMONT UNION SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND SANTEE SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO HONOR. THE
DIFFERENTIATION OF ETHNICITY AND
TO CREATE A CATEGORY FAR
ASSYRIAN AND CHALDEAN STUDENTS
ON PUPILS REGISTRATION
PAPERWORK.
CURRENTLY THE SYRIANS AND CAL D.
ENDS ARE IDENTIFIED AS MIDDLE
EASTERN UNDER ETHNIC
DEMOGRAPHICS ON PAPERWORK. WHEN
IN FACT THEY ARE MESOPOTAMIA.
INTERESTING. THAT ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT SEVENTY ONE IS HOME TO
THE SECOND LARGEST ASSYRIAN
CHALDEAN AND SYRIAC COMMUNITIES
IN THE UNITED STATES.
AFTER MICHIGAN.
TWENTY PERCENT.
SYRIAN REFUGEES.
COME.
A DISTRICT SEVENTY ONE.
THERE'S APPROXIMATELY SIXTY
THOUSAND CHALDEAN ASSYRIANS.
SYRIAC COMMUNITY.
WE DON'T HAVE AN EXACT COUNT.
BUT I ANTICIPATE.
THAT NUMBER TWO RIVAL OR SURPASS
THE CURRENT.
.
MESOPOTAMIAN POPULATION.
SO THIS IS A NEW ETHNIC GROUP.
THAT IS
LIKE MANY ETHNIC GROUPS.
TRYING
AND BE RECOGNIZED.
INTERESTING TO ME.
SOMETIME IN HOPEFULLY THE
DISTANT FUTURE.
YOU WILL HAVE AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF CAL DE AND A SYRIAN OR.
SYRIAN.
D. SENT BEFORE YOU REPRESENTING
SEVENTY FIRST DISTRICT
NO DOUBT MY MINE ONCE AGAIN I
HOPE IT'S IN THE FAR FUTURE AT
LEAST TWELVE YEARS FROM NOW.
WITH THE WARS IN SYRIA MANY
ASSYRIAN CHALDEAN AND SYRIAC
REFUGEES HAVE FOUND A HOME IN MY
DISTRICT.
STRANGELY ENOUGH.
WHETHER THEY'RE CHRISTIAN OR
MUSLIM.
THEY GET ALONG. GROWN GREATLY.
VERY FEW.
INCIDENTS OR IF I'M.
ITEMS OF FRICTION THERE SO GLAD
TO BE IN AMERICA.
AND TO HAVE A CHANCE TO BECOME
AMERICANS.
LET ME TELL YOU A THEY'LL OUT
CITIZEN YOU.
I BELIEVE THAT AB TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHTS SEEKS TO PROMOTE
DIVERSITY AND GUIDES MY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
SERVE AS GOOD EXAMPLES TO OTHERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION OF
CALIFORNIADETERMINES.
THE ETHNIC CATEGORIES.
WITH THIS SAID I HAVE EL CAJON
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER BEND QALAT
SHOW.
SPEAK WITH THE CHAIRS
PERMISSION.
THANK YOU YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY MY NAME IS BEN
KALASH CHAU COUNCILMAN FOR THE
CITY OF EL CAJON. IN THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO.
I'M HERE TODAY NOT ONLY IN MY
OFFICIAL CAPACITY BUT ALSO ON A
PERSONAL LEVEL.
AND AS THIS A BILL IMMENSELY
AFFECTS MY LIFE AND MANY MANY
OTHERS WHO WITHIN THE DISTRICT
STATEWIDE ALSO NATIONALLY.
WHEN I CONTACTED ASSEMBLYMAN
RANDY VOEPEL IS OFFICE LAST YEAR
REGARDING THIS BILL HE
IMMEDIATELY KNEW AND UNDERSTOOD
THE IMPORTANCE. THAT THIS BILL
WOULD HAVE ON MY COMMUNITY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
EIGHT WILL HELP MY COMMUNITY.
THOSE WHO ORIGINATED FROM
MESOPOTAMIA.
THE LAND BETWEEN TWO RIVERS AND
MORE MODERNLY KNOWN BY THEIR
SUBPOPULATION NAMES ASSYRIAN
CHALDEAN AND SYRIAC TO BE A
PROTECTED MINORITY CLASS.
NOW WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO BE
PROTECTED MINORITY CLASS WITHIN
THE CONTEXT%
BUT I WAS PRESENTING HERE TODAY.
SIMPLY PUT IN ACADEMIA ASSYRIAN
CHALDEAN SYRIAC STUDENTS WOULD
THEN BE ABLE TO CHECK OFF THE
APPROPRIATE BOX OF THEIR ORIGIN.
NOW THIS HAS A MULTITUDE OF
BENEFITS FOR MY COMMUNITY
BECAUSE NOT ONLY WILL WE BE ABLE
TO TRACK HOW WELL WE ARE DOING
IN SCHOOL BUT WILL BE ABLE TO
DECIPHER WHICH SUBJECTS WERE
ATTRACTED TO.
AND MOREOVER WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE
TO DECIPHER WHERE IN THE A
COMMUNITY IN THE STATE OUR SUB
POPULATION RESIDES WITH RESPECT
TO THE CENSUS.
NOW I AM HERE TODAY SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
OF MY COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO
RESIDE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M SPEAKING FOR HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF OTHERS WITHIN THIS.
THE COUNTRY WHO ARE LOOKING AT
THIS DAY AND LOOKING AT ME TO
ADOPT SIMILAR RESOLUTIONS IN
THEIR STATES.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY AS YOU KNOW
MY PEOPLE LIVE IN THE DIASPORA
BECAUSE OF THE RISE OF TERRORIST
GROUPS LIKE ISIS. THEIR
DISPLACED
BUT THEY WANT TO KNOW THAT IF
THEY COME HERE. THAT THEY'RE
ACCOUNTED FOR NOT LIKELY WHAT
HAPPENED UNDER ICE IS THEY WANT
TO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
RECOGNIZED AND NOT ONLY DID.
AND SO. I'M HERE TODAY TO TO
REPRESENT THOSE PEOPLE THOSE
VOICELESS PEOPLE I DID BRING A
LITTLE PROFIT. BUT ASSEMBLYMAN
RANDY VOEPEL TOLD ME THAT WE
DON'T DO THAT BUT I WANT TO JUST
READ IT READ OUT TO YOU. QUICKLY
GET.
YOUR AT YOUR TIME LIMIT NOW SO
JUST VERY BRIEFLY IF YOU WERE
SURE AND I THINK USES THANKS SO
MUCH.
WHAT WERE ASKING FOR EVENTUALLY
IS A CATEGORY TO SAY
MESOPOTAMIAN ASSYRIAN CHALDEAN
SYRIAC BECAUSE THAT'S WHO WE
IDENTIFY WITH AND I THINK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY?
GIVE ANY QUESTIONS I'LL BE MORE
THAN HAPPY I THINK YOU THINK YOU
CALPERS WHAT DO I. CLARIFY
SOMETHING I THINK I THINK IT
YET.
STATED THAT THIS WOULD MAKE.
CREATE A PROTECTED CLASS THAT'S
NOT WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO THIS
NOTICE REQUIRE THE DISTRICT
ACCOUNT THEM. WHICH
THE DISTRICT COULD DO TODAY SURE
SO DESIRED EVENTUALLY IS WHAT I
WANT SO I WITH THAT.
DO WE HAVE OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
CHIEF OF STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION OF THE
BILL. GOOD AFTERNOON IS ROMAN
TASH PRESIDENT THE SYRIAN
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARTIN
YOU MARK ON THE PRESIDENT OF THE
ASSYRIAN AMERICAN NATIONAL
FEDERATION I CAME ALL THE WAY TO
SHIFT FROM CHICAGO. IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU THINK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOSEPH
BABA REPRESENTING SACRAMENTO
ASSYRIAN CLUB WHEN IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
INTERVIEWED IN TODAY'S MY LAST
DAY IN MEDICAL SCHOOL SO
TOMORROW EGGMAN DOCTOR ENTERED
IN.
I'M I WAS A COURSE LECTURE AT UC
BERKELEY STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON THE BILL
ONLY SIR.
I WANT SUPPORT IT AND WE DID A
SIMILAR THING WITH THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
WITH AN ASSYRIAN CALIFORNIA
CHECK VICE YOU FIVE YEARS AGO.
THANK YOU. GREAT ANY OTHERS IS A
BLESSING TO OTHERS ANY
OPPOSITION THE BILL.
HE WILL BRING IT BACK.
AND AGAIN I.
THE STRUGGLE I APPRECIATE.
I'M NOT OPPOSED YOUR GOAL PUT
YOUR GOAL TO BE ACHIEVED AT THE
DISTRICT COULD.
PROVIDE THIS DATA PUBLICLY
TODAY.
SO I REALLY DON'T UNDERSTAND IT
CREATING A STATE MANDATE WHICH
STATE WOULD HAVE TO PAY FOR FOR
THE DISTRICT CONDUCT THAT. THAT
STUDY.
VIDEO I DON'T KNOW WHY WE'RE
HEADING DOWN THAT PATH AGAIN
THEY COULD START THIS TOMORROW
IF THEY DON'T ALREADY DO IT AND
I WOULD. YOU KNOW SO I I ALMOST
WONDER IF YOU SHOULD BE TALKING
TO THE SCHOOL BOARD.
RATHER THAN THE STATE EDUCATION
CAN
BECAUSE AGAIN THEY COULD DO THIS
TODAY.
DON'T KNOW IT'S NECESSARY TO
CREATE A STATEWIDE MANDATE AND
IT DOES NOT.
CREATE A PROTECTED CLASS SO I I
I SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE STRUGGLING
THAT'S WE SEE THAT IN THE END
NOW.
SENATE WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT.
BUT MISTER KELLY DID YOU WISH TO
COME.
SO WITH THAT.
THANK YOU YOU MAY CLOSE YES SIR.
ONCE AGAIN I UNDERSTAND THE.
CONCERNS OF THE COMMITTEE CHAIR.
OF.
BECAUSE
THE QUESTIONNAIRES ARE DESIGNED
BY THE PARTNER OF EDUCATION OF
CALIFORNIA IT WAS THOUGHT.
BY MY CONSTITUENTS THAT THAT'S
WHERE IT NEEDED TO GO.
SO THAT'S. THE RULING THERE. AS
FAR AS PROTECTED CLASS NAT
THAT'S A BATTLE FOR THEM TO WAGE
AT SOME FUTURE TIME.
I RESPECTFULLY S. FOR A YES
VOTE.
AND HOPEFULLY THIS CAN MAKE IT
TO THE FLOOR
THANK YOU SIR GETTING GONNA
TWENTY REITERATED CAN BE DONE
LOCALLY NOW IN FACT SOME
DISTRICTS ALREADY DO THIS THE
CREATE THEIR OWN FORM.
UNDER NEW TO STAY LOCKED ON THE
GOVERNOR DON'T NEED JONAH.
BUT AGAIN I THANK YOU FOR
REPRESENTING YOUR COMMUNITY WELL
TODAY
AND THANK YOU COUNCILMAN FOR
PRESENTING TODAY
SO THAT WERE NOT TO MAKE A
MOTION AS WE DON'T OF A QUORUM
YET. AND AGAIN I THANK YOU THAT
YOU.
OUR NEXT.
IS NEXT IS OF MISTER VOEPEL
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER AND
GALLAGHER PRESIDENT.
AREAS.
IN HERE MISTER GALLAGHER WILL
RESENT AB TWO SIX TWO ZERO SIX
SEVEN TWO ZERO SIX SEVEN.
IT'S ITEM NUMBER EIGHT PILOT
RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
OF THIS THIS MORNING.
.
AB TWENTY SIXTY SEVEN.
IS MY BILL A DILEMMA SCHOOL
SAFETY IN HAVING. ARMED SECURITY
AT OUR.
SCHOOLS.
AND I FIRST WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
THROUGH FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE ON THIS WE ARE PREPARED
TO TAKE. OF THE AMENDMENT
SUGGESTED REGARDING.
.
REMOVING PRIVATE.
SCHOOL SECURITY GUARDS AND ALSO
INCLUDING CHARTER SCHOOLS.
IN THIS MANDATE. AND SO WE
WOULD TAKE THOSE THOSE TWO
AMENDMENTS AND.
AND.
.
YEAH THIS THIS ISSUE REALLY
OBVIOUSLY CAME.
.
VERY CLOSE TO HOME FOR US IN IN
MY DISTRICT.
Z. AS YOU HEARD A LITTLE BIT
EARLIER TODAY IN THE COMMITTEE.
THE SMALL SCHOOL OF RANCHO TO
HIM AND MY DISTRICT.
JUST.
WEST OF THE COMMUNITY A CORNY
AND TAMAR COUNTY.
.
HAD A VERY TRAGIC ATTACK.
AND THAT MAN WENT ON A RAMPAGE
TO THIS COMMUNITY.
I ULTIMATELY GOING ON TO THE
SCHOOL GROUNDS R. RANCHO TO HIM
ELEMENTARY.
AT THE END OF THE DAY FIVE
PEOPLE WERE KILLED.
.
A COMMUNITY WAS COMPLETELY
DEVASTATED AND.
AND.
YOU KNOW A SCHOOL.
AND IN CHILDREN WERE LOCKED IN
THEIR CLASSROOMS.
BEING SHOT AT FROM OUTSIDE THE
CLASSROOM BY THIS BY THIS GUN
MEN.
YOU KNOW IN TALKING WITH THE
STAFF. AND TEACHERS AFTERWARDS
SO YOU CAN IMAGINE OBVIOUSLY
THE.
THE*.
THAT THEY WENT THROUGH AND AS
THIS WAS TRANSPIRING.
BUT ALSO THAT THE GREAT COURAGE
THAT WE SAW OUT OF THE STAFF
MEMBERS AND TEACHERS. WHO WERE
ABLE TO LOCK DOWN THE CLASSROOM?
AND THEY HAD HAD TRAINING.
.
AS MISTER RODRIGUEZ BILLETS IS
PROPOSING TO DO.
AND THEY ACTED VERY QUICKLY AND
THEY SAVE LIVES THAT DAY BECAUSE
OF WHAT THEY DID.
WE ALSO DID HAVE A A COMMUNITY
MEMBER WHO.
WHO DISTRACTED THE GUNMAN AS HE
WAS SHOOTING INTO CLASSROOMS AND
ALSO THEY GOT HIM TO?
YOU KNOW COME OUT OF THE SCHOOL
GROUNDS.
.
AND SO THERE WAS A LOT OF
HEROISM THAT HAPPEN THERE TO
HELP SAVE LIVES THAT DAY.
BUT AS AS YOU KNOW AS WE
CONSIDER THE THINGS THAT WE NEED
TO DO IN THE AFTERMATH OF THESE
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
OTHERS SO MANY THERE'S MULTIPLE
PRONGS HERE WE KNOW THERE'S
MULTIPLE THINGS WE NEED TO DO.
AND.
AT TO STOP THIS BUT THAT THE SAD
REALITY IS THAT WE ARE SEEN
THESE.
HORRENDOUS ATTACKS.
GO TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE OUR
KIDS OUR MOST PRECIOUS.
COMMODITY IN THE STATE.
ARE VULNERABLE.
TO THESE TO THESE ATTACKS AND
SO.
YOU KNOW IS I WAS THINKING ABOUT
HOW WE CAN DO BETTER.
I WAS CONSIDERING THAT IN THE
SCHOOL RESA RESOURCE OFFICER
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE THAT MANY
SCHOOLS.
THAT HAS BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
AND WHY NOT HAVE THESE
INDIVIDUALS AT EVERY AND EVERY
SCHOOL IN THE STATE. A TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S GONNA BE SOMEONE
THERE.
WHO WOULD BE ABLE TO STOP THESE
ATTACKS WHEN THEY HAPPENED THAT
WE WOULDN'T JUST HAVE TO HOLD UP
IN OUR CLASSROOMS AND HOPE?
THAT SOMETHING DOESN'T MORE
DIRE DOESN'T HAPPEN.
ALL THOSE THINGS NEED TO BE
DONE WE NEED TO HAVE TRAINING.
BUT WE NEED TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO
CAN BE A FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE.
AND YOU KNOW I THINK THE MERITS
OF THIS POLICY.
.
NO REALLY WERE SHOWN YESTERDAY
IN MARYLAND.
WHERE WE HAD ENOUGH SORROW?
A WHO ACTED LEGALLY IN.
IN SECONDS.
UNDER A MINUTE I WON THE FIRST.
WHEN THE SHOOTING BEGAN AT A
SCHOOL THERE IN MARYLAND AND WAS
ABLE TO DISPATCH.
AND STOP THE SHOOTER.
FROM CARRYING OUT MORE THE.
FOR SHE MORE STUDENTS ON CAMPUS
ARE STILL WAS TRAGICALLY TO
PEOPLE SHOT.
BUT CLEARLY EVERYBODY THAT. HAS
REPORT ON THIS IS SAID THIS THIS
HELP STOP AND HELP PREVENT. FEET
MORE LOSS OF LIFE.
.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN THIS ACTUALLY
YOU KNOW THE S. AROSE DOWN AND
ACTUALLY SELLING CALIFORNIA
THAT.
SECURITY GUARD WHO OVERHEARD A
CONVERSATION ULTIMATELY WAS ABLE
TO GO SEARCH A.
STUDENTS HOMEROOM WHEN THEY
FOUND WEAPONS WERE ABLE TO WHAT
THEY BELIEVE PREVENT.
WHAT COULD HAVE BEEN AN ATTACK
AS WELL SO THIS IS A GOOD
PROGRAM THAT WORKS THE S. R. AW
UP PROGRAMS AND WHAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR THIS BILL IS THAT?
THERE WOULD BE AN SRO A TRAINED.
PEACE OFFICER ON EVERY CAMPUS.
THIS WOULD BE A REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE.
FOR OUR SCHOOLS.
AND IT WOULD APPLY ACROSS THE
BOARD NOW WITH THE AMENDMENTS TO
CHARTER SCHOOLS AS WELL AND AND
SO.
I WOULD ASK YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS MEASURE I THINK IT'S A
MUCH NEEDED.
.
NO DEFENSE YEAH THERE'S GOING TO
BE A CASA THAT LOBBYISTS HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THAT APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. BUT FOR ME YOU KNOW I
DON'T THINK YOU CAN PUT A PRICE
ON PEACE OF MIND WHEN IT COMES
TO OUR KIDS INSIDE ASK YOUR. AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN. FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION A MEMBERS THINK I
DO HAVE SOME WITNESSES WITH ME
AND SUPPORT WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
TWO MINUTES EACH POLICEMAN.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M KAREN VIA
LOBOS.
TWIN RIVERS CHARTER SCHOOL
FORMALLY EAST NICHOLAS HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF A SRO. AS I TALK TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER IT'S
AS PREVENTIVE AS IT IS THE
INCIDENT WE KNOW THAT EFFECTIVE
BEST SORROWS BUILD RELATIONSHIPS
WITH STUDENTS WE KNOW STUDENTS.
ARE MOST LIKELY GOING TO BE THE
PERPETRATORS AND IF WE CAN BE
PREVENTIVE. AND HOW THAT
RELATIONSHIP ON CAMPUS IT'S
GOING TO SAVE LIVES AS WELL.
MY NAME IS DAN RAMOS AND I'VE
WORKED WITH C. PRINCIPLE LAS
PLUMAS HIGH SCHOOL ONE OR OF ALL
FOR NINE YEARS I ALSO HAVE
SEVENTEEN YEARS EXPERIENCE AS AN
EMERGENCY MEDICAL TECHNICIAN AND
VOLUNTEER FIRE CAPTAIN WITH
BUTTE COUNTY FIRE. WHERE I'VE
RECEIVED ADVANCED TRAINING AN
ACTIVE SHOOTER TRAUMA RESPONSE?
IN SEPTEMBER TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
I WAS THE ADMINISTRATOR IN
CHARGE AT THE TIME WHEN AN ARM
STUDENT GREAT RIGHT TOOK NEARLY
THIRTY HOSTAGES. IN OUR BAND
ROOM.
A STANDOFF ENSUED THE GUNMEN
FIRED TWO SHOTS HOWEVER NO ONE
WAS INJURED.
WE DID NOT HAVE A SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICER ON CAMPUS THAT
DAY.
I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIXTY SEVEN AS I RECALL THE
LONELY AND.
TERRIFYING FEELING THE TAKES
HOLD WHILE WE WAITED FOR ABOUT
SEVEN MINUTES FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ARRIVE AND TAKE
CHARGE OF THE SITUATION.
AND THAT AMOUNT OF TIME WE COULD
EASILY BEEN AT THE TOP OF THE
LIST OF DEADLY SCHOOL INCIDENTS
IN THE NATION. WE'RE JUST LUCKY.
I ALSO KNOW THAT IMMEDIATE ARMED
OPPOSITION IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAY TO STOP AN ACTIVE SHOOTER.
ALONG WITH MY SUPPORT I URGE HIS
BODY TO ENSURE THAT THE SCHOOLS
ARE FULLY FUNDED TO SUPPORT THE
PLACEMENT OF ARMED LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN RURAL
SCHOOLS.
ATTENTION MUST BE PAID TO HOW
FUNNY AND WE'LL GET TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AS THE MANDATED COST
REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM HAS NOT
BEEN A RELIABLE. OR TIMELY
SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS.
CURRENTLY THE MANDATED COSTS
FUNDS THAT ARE DISTRICT RECEIVES
WOULD BARELY SUPPORT THE ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR YOUR PRICE TAG. OF ONE
DEPUTY THAT ROTATES BETWEEN FOR
SCHOOLS WITHOUT ALLOWING A
SINGLE DOLLAR FINE OTHER STATE
MANDATED ACTIVITIES.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT YOU TAKE
SCHOOL SAFETY SERIOUSLY AND
TARGET FINDING THOSE FULLY AND
SPECIFICALLY SUPPORTING ARMED
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN
SCHOOLS.
ADDITIONALLY I FEEL THAT SWORN
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ARE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE FORM OF SECURITY
IN SCHOOLS THEY HAVE THE
TRAINING EQUIPMENT DIRECT
ACCESS.
TO OTHER AGENCIES THAT IS NEEDED
TO RESPOND A MAJOR VIOLENT
INCIDENTS.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT MAKE UP THE MICROPHONE
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION. AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
REFERENCED LA CARTE ARMED GUARDS
SECURITY TRAINING ACADEMY IN
FULL SUPPORT.
THERE GOES A WEIRDO I'M GONNA
FIVE REDUCTION IN FULL SUPPORT.
MISTER FRANCIS GUERRILLAS DOCTOR
VELOS YUBA COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LIEUTENANT STEVE BOYD FROM THE
BUTTE COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE ON
BEHALF OF FEAR OF KOREA ONLY.
FULL SUPPORT.
CHARLES TRACY FORMER POLICE
OFFICER HOSTAGE NEGOTIATOR FOR
LYNDHURST HIGH SCHOOL NINETEEN
NINETY TWO. AND SUPERINTENDENT A
HAMILTON UNIFIED IN FULL
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANY OPPOSITION
.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
KATHY SHORT FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA WE RESPECTFULLY NOLES
DEPOSED AB TWENTY TWENTY SIXTY
SEVEN.
WE ALL AGREE THAT SCHOOL SAFETY
IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL CHILDREN
SHOULD BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON
LEARNING WITHOUT WORRYING ABOUT
THEIR PERSONAL SAFETY. PARENTS
TO FEEL THAT SCHOOL IS A PLACE
WHERE THEIR CHILDREN WILL BE
PROTECTED FROM HARM.
THE MISSION OF EDUCATING OUR
CHILDREN HOUSE TO START WITH
PROVIDING A SAFE PLACE TO LEARN.
WE DISAGREE AS TO HOW TO MAKE
SURE OUR SCHOOLS ARE SAFE.
PUTTING A GUARD OR OFFICER IN
EVERY SCHOOL AS AB TWENTY SIXTY
SEVEN PROPOSES TO DO IS NOT THE
ANSWER.
PUTTING GUNS IN SCHOOLS IN THE
HANDS OF SECURITY GUARDS OR
SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICERS OR
ANYONE ELSE.
WILL MAKE SCHOOLS LESS SAFE NOT
MORE SUBTLE.
WE SAW THIS WITH THE INCIDENT
MONTEREY LAST WEEK WHERE THREE
STUDENTS WERE INJURED BY A
TEACHER WHO WAS ALSO A RESERVE
POLICE OFFICER. ACCIDENTALLY
DISCHARGING A GUN IN CLASS.
BUT THE PROBLEM WITH PLACING A
SECURITY GUARD A RESOURCE
OFFICER AT EVERY SCHOOL EXTENDS
FAR BEYOND THE RISK OF THE USE
OF THAT PERSON'S GOT.
FOR MANY STUDENTS THE PRESENCE
OF AN ARMED OFFICER MAKE SCHOOL
FEEL MORE LIKE A DETENTION
CENTERS ON A SCHOOL.
A PLACE WHERE THEY ARE SEEN AS
SUSPECTS.
SADLY ALL TOO OFTEN THAT FEELING
IS REINFORCED WHEN OFFICERS ON
CAMPUS ARE BROUGHT INTO WHAT
SHOULD BE ROUTINE SCHOOL
DISCIPLINARY MATTERS. ONLY TO
ESCALATE THE INCIDENT TO THE
POINT SOMETIMES OF USING
EXCESSIVE FORCE AGAINST
STUDENTS.
WE'VE ALL SEEN THE VIDEOS IN
CALIFORNIA AND ELSEWHERE.
STUDENTS PUSHED WERE THROWN TO
THE GROUND BY OFFICERS IN THEIR
SCHOOLS.
SOMETIMES WERE OFFENSES AS MINOR
AS FAILING TO PUT AWAY A CELL
PHONE.
FOR THESE STUDENTS AND MANY
OTHERS THE PRESENCE OF A SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICER FEELS LIKE A
THREAT NOT A SOURCE OF
PROTECTION.
WE NEED TO BE LOOKING FOR WAYS
TO REDUCE THE PRESENCE OF POLICE
IN OUR SCHOOLS NOT TO INCREASE
THE.
WE KNOW HOW TO KEEP OUR SCHOOLS
SAFE.
WE NEED TO MAKE OUR SCHOOLS INTO
WELCOMING AN INCLUSIVE PLACES.
THAT SUPPORT THE SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL HEALTH OF THE STUDENTS
AND THAT HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO BUILD COMMUNITY AND
ADDRESS CONFLICT WITH NON
PUNITIVE METHODS.
LET'S FOCUS ON PROVIDING STE
SCHOOLS WITH THOSE RESOURCES
RATHER THAN INVESTING IN
EXPENSIVE MEASURES THAT WILL
JUST MAKE THINGS WORSE.
WE ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE THANK
YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
TONY TO CAROL AND HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE A RECOMMENDED OPPOSE
POSITION ON THIS BILL.
SARAH MUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS IN OPPOSITION.
RON RAPOPORT HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WERE ALSO TAKING IN
OPPOSE RECOMMENDATION TO OUR
CONVENTION.
KAI JACKSON WAS SENDING UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION.
SIR HUTCHINSON WITHOUT FOR WOMEN
AND GIRLS AND VICE IDEA WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ANY BLOOMBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION AND WE DO NOT HAVE
AN OFFICIAL POSITION BUT WE DO
HAVE CONCERNED WITH BEING
INCLUDED IN THE BILL AND THE
FISCAL IMPACT.
ERNIE SILVA SCIENTIFIC CHARTER
SCHOOL WE WILL ALSO BE TAKING
THE POST POSITION.%
THANK YOU SEE NO OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
I MANY COMMENTS ON THE
COMMITTEE.
I I HAVE A COMMENT.
.
I THINK A BILL. AND I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU WANT PEACE OFFICERS.
NOT IN A GUARD THEY MIGHT'VE
GONE THROUGH TWO WEEK EIGHT
THIRTY TWO CLASS WHICH THAT'S
NOT THE SAME THING SOME IS
TRAINED IN THE AREA OF OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND I THINK YOU'RE NOT ASKING
THESE OFFICERS IN IRAQ THE
STUDENTS AS FAR AS DISCIPLINE
THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU'RE SEEKING
HERE. YOU'RE SEEKING SIMPLY TO
KEEP THE FACILITY IN THE PEOPLE
IN AND AROUND THAT FACILITY
SAFE.
AND AS ONE OF COMES FROM.
HIGH SCHOOL A FIFTY TWO HUNDRED
KIDS.
OKAY WITH TWO SHERIFF'S.
USUALLY.
ON CAMPUS ON AROUND IT'S ALSO
AROUND IN THIS AFTER SCHOOL
HOURS I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THIS.
IF YOU HAVEN'T HAD THAT
EXPERIENCE YOU HAVEN'T SEEN THE
MASSIVE PEOPLE.
AND THE ACTIVITY SURROUNDING
VERY URBAN HIGH SCHOOL YOU MIGHT
THE YOU KNOW AFRAID OF THIS
CONCEPT BUT IF YOU'VE INTERACTED
AND SEEN THIS LIVE DID. I THINK
HE'D BE MUCH MORE SUPPORTIVE.
AND ANY FIFTY TWO HUNDRED YEAR
OF HIGH SCHOOL FIFTY TWO HUNDRED
IS A SMALL CITY.
SMALL CITIES HAVE POLICE
OFFICERS TO. FOR THE VERY SAME
REASON SO I AM SUPPORTIVE I
THINK THERE ARE OTHERS WHO WISH
TO COMMENT MISTER THURMAN.
NO MISTER LACKEY I'M SORRY.
SELECT ANY JEWISH. OKAY LIKE A
SUBHEADING GO.
I WANT TO.
.
THANK THE AUTHOR FOREVER THE
COURAGE TO BRING THIS FORWARD AT
THIS VERY DELICATE TIME.
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS A VERY VERY
DISTURBING PROBLEM IN OUR
SOCIETY.
AND OTHER REMEDIES ART ALL THAT
SIMPLE.
BUT ONE THING THAT I THINK IS TO
SHOULD RESONATE VERY CLEARLY. AS
IT IS NOT OKAY TO LEAVE ALL OF
OUR CHILDREN.
DEFENSELESS.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE DONE.
WE'VE HAD SOME GOOD WELL
INTENDED POLICIES.
WITHIN OUR STATE AND WITHIN
LOCAL CONTROL.
BUT ONE THING CLEARLY.
NOT OKAY TO LEAVE.
A BODY OF CHILDREN.
THAT HAVE BEEN INTERESTED.
DEFENSELESS.
AND I THINK.
THIS IS A REASONABLE.
POINTED THERE'D BEEN A LOT OF
PROPOSALS AND I THINK.
THIS ONE SHOULD RESONATE IN.
HAD TO SAY THAT.
SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN GIVEN.
THE.
.
THE PRIVILEGE TO POSSIBLY BEEN
SACRIFICE THEIR LIFE.
FOR THE BENEFIT OF OTHERS AS A
THREAT.
TO THEM AS.
UNIMAGINABLE TO ME.
SO I'VE I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND I THINK IT
MAKES.
GOOD COMMON SENSE BECAUSE WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING.
THANK YOU.
I MISTER DURBIN.
I AM SUCH YEAR UMP TO THE AUTHOR
I'D JUST WANT SOME CLARIFICATION
BECAUSE AS WE DISCUSS THIS BILL.
YOU SHARED WITH ME THAT YOUR
BILL WOULD.
.
REQUIRE SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICERS
SAID THEY'RE STILL LANGUAGE HERE
AND REFERENCES.
TO ARMED SECURITY GUARDS ALLOW I
HAVE DEEP RESPECT FOR THE WORK
THAT THOSE WHO WERE IN ARMY
SECURITY.
AGENCIES DO ARM I HAVE WORKED
FOR MANY YEARS WAS SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICERS AND.
I I HAVE A DIFFERENT LEVEL OF
COMFORT.
WITH THOSE SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICERS WHO HAVE WORKED WITH ON
BECAUSE I HAVE EXPERIENCED THEM.
TO.
UNDERSTAND THAT FIRST THING THEY
DO IS BUILD A RELATIONSHIP WITH
STUDENTS.
TO DO PREVENTIVE WORK THAT THEY
CAN AND THEN WHEN THERE IS A
SITUATION LIKE WHEN A CHILD.
CALLS THEIR PARA AND SAYS DAD.
OUR SCHOOLS UNDER LOCKDOWN
BECAUSE WE HAVE A GUN ON CAMPUS
I RECEIVED A CALL.
AT YALE. A SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICER KNOWS HOW TO GO FROM
BEING A PREVENTIVE OFFICER.
TWO BEING A IN A LAW ENFORCEMENT
SAFETY UP RESPONSE AND SO.
BUT I'D BE CONCERNED IF WERE
TALKING ABOUT OPENING IT UP TO
US THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE THE SAME
LEVEL OF TRAINING. OF A SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICER BECAUSE THEY'RE
TOO MANY VARIABLES THAT CAN
HAPPEN IN HAVE HAPPENED YOU KNOW
THE KIDS HAVE BEEN. MISTREATED
AND ALL NUMBER OF CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE PEOPLE OF IMPROVISED.
AND WE KNOW THAT SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICERS CAN NEVER BE USED.
AS THE DISCIPLINE AREAS FOR.
WHAT STUDENTS DO KIDS ARE GONNA
DO WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO?
AND SO I AS I SHARE WITH YOU ARE
IF THIS IS A BILL TO PUT GUNS ON
CAMPUS IN A WAY THAT. COULD
REALLY OPEN THE STUFF FOR A
RECKLESS BEHAVIOR OR
MISINTERPRETATION OR THOSE WHO
HAVEN'T HAD THE PROPER TRAINING.
BEING ASKED TO DEFEND THE
SITUATION THAT COULD GET EVEN
WORSE I WILL SUPPORT IT.
NOT IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CUTE
SCHOOL RESOURCE PATTERSON ONLY.
WHO HAD THE PROPER TRAINING?
WHERE THERE IS A PROPER
OVERSIGHT WHERE THEY WILL NOT BE
AN EXPECTATION THAT THEY WILL BE
USED OR MISUSED?
THE B. THE DEANS OF THE
DISCIPLINARIAN SUBSTANTIVE
BEHAVIOR ON CAMPUS THAT I THINK
WE HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH
HAPPY WOULD YOU PLEASE CLARIFY.
YEAH. THANK YOU MISTER THURMOND
AND.
I AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION WE'VE HAD ABOUT
THIS BILL AND AND AND YOUR
EXPERIENCE. YOU HAVE BEEN WORKED
ON THE SCHOOLS AND WORKED WITH.
.
JUSTIN RESOURCE OFFICERS A
SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICERS WAS WAS
VERY APPARENT TO ME.
JUST SO YOU KNOW WE ARE TAKING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT.
THAT WOULD REMOVE PRIVATE
SECURITY FROM BEING PART OF THIS
IS WOULD ONLY BE.
SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICERS.
PIECE ORIGINALLY WHEN I DID
THAT I MEAN THERE ARE SOME
PRIVATE SECURITY FIRMS OUT THERE
WHO HAVE.
THE ADDITIONAL TRAINING.
BUT I HEARD THE CONCERN. THAT
WE WANT SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICERS
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENT IT WOULD ONLY BE
SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICERS IN THIS
IN THIS BILL THANKS FOR
CLARIFICATION FIFTEEN AMENDMENT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
THERE MISTER CHAIR. ON THAT
WOULD YOU SPEAK TO THE OTHER KEY
PROVISIONS BECAUSE THEY'RE GONNA
BE PEOPLE.
WHO HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE
CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT THIS COULD TURN INTO
EVEN WITH IT BEING SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICERS IN?
THERE HAVE BEEN MISS USES AND
ABUSES OF SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICER PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE. THAT HAVE LED TO CHILDREN
BEING CRIMINALIZE
FOR CARRYING OUT THE BEHAVIORS
THAT KIDS CARRY OUT.
I GUESS I'M ASKING YOU TO SPEAK
TO HOW. WE ARE STRUCTURING THIS
SO THAT THOSE THINGS DON'T
HAPPEN
TRAINING AND EXPECTATION SO THAT
THESE ARE NOT OFFICER IS BEING
USED TO TAKE OVER WHAT SHOULD
BE.
WORK DONE BY THE SCHOOL STAFF
TO ADDRESS STUDENT BEHAVIOR.
I KNOW I'M DEFINITELY SENSITIVE
TO THOSE CONCERNS.
AND YOU KNOW ONE THING IS THERE
IS SOURCE OFFICER IT'S MORE THAN
JUST BEING A PEACE OFFICER IT'S
MORE THAN JUST HAVING POST
TRAINING. THERE'S ADDITIONAL
TRADE ON TOP OF THAT THAT GOES
INTO HOW YOU ENGAGE WITH
STUDENTS.
IN ORDER TO BECOME AN ACTUAL
SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICER SO THERE
IS THAT ADDITIONAL TRAINING
HERE.
YA AS WITH ALL. YOU KNOW KIND
OF BIG BILLS LIKE THIS.
YOU KNOW THIS IS STILL A WORK
IN PROGRESS AND I'M STILL
WANTING TO WORK WITH ALL THE
STAKE HOLDERS ON THIS.
TO MAKE SURE IT ADDRESSES ALL
THOSE DIFFERENT CONCERNS.
YOU KNOW I'VE HEARD YOU KNOW
SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT IS THERE
MAYBE SCHOOLS THAT ALREADY HAVE
THE RESOURCE OFFICER OR. YOU
HAVE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS MAY BE
IS THERE AN OPT OUT KNEW THAT
SOMETHING THAT WE COULD DISCUSS.
YOU AS WE MOVE FOR BUT I'D I
DEFTLY INSENSITIVE TO THOSE
ISSUES YOU WANT TO ENSURE THAT.
THAT THIS PERSON IS IN A PLACE
OF OF OF OBVIOUSLY FIRST FIRST
ALL DEFENSIVE THE SCHOOL IF
THERE IS SOME SORT OF THREAT.
BUT ALSO AS A POSITIVE
RELATIONSHIP.
WITH THE KIDS ON THE CAMPUS AND.
YOU KNOW FOR THERE IS A GREAT
ARTICLE IN MY LOCAL PAPER JUST
RECENTLY ABOUT A SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICER MARYSVILLE HIGH SCHOOL.
AND HOW HIS IN HIS ENGAGEMENT ON
CAMPUSES HAD A VERY POSITIVE.
ENVIRONMENT FOR THE ENTIRE
CAMPUS AND I KNOW YOU'VE SEEN
THAT IN RICHMOND AS WELLSO.
WERE DEFTLY WANTED TO ENGAGE ON
THAT AND AGAIN THIS IS IN THE
FINAL PRODUCT AS WELL AS REMOVAL
FOR WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
THAT DISCUSSION AND I'M.
WOULD LOVE TO CONTINUE TO
DISCUSS THIS WITH YOU SO.
EDU WELL I I TO YOUR POINT YOU
KNOW NOT BEING A SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICER IS NOT THE JOB FOR EVERY
OFFICER.
ARE THERE ARE SOME OFFICERS WHO
DON'T WANT TO WORKING
ENVIRONMENT.
THAT IS PREVENTION FIRST LAW
ENFORCEMENT SECOND BUILDING A
RELATIONSHIP WITH STUDENTS AND.
.
THE LEVEL PREVENTIVE STUFF THAT
CAN HAPPEN AND SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR APPROACH TO THIS
I DO THINK THAT THERE'S AN ELF
IN THE ROOM THAT'S GOT TO GET
DRESSED AND THAT IS.
THAT HISTORICALLY THEIR
DISCIPLINE BAD RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AND VARIOUS GROUPS IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT KIDS OF COLOR AND
OTHERS. AND THERE'S A HUGE LEVEL
DISTRESS I THINK WE DON'T TALK
ABOUT IT WE DO OURSELVES IN A
JUSTICE IN A DISSERVICE.
AND SO IN THAT RESPECT I'M
ASKING YOU AS YOU OFFER THE BILL
WHAT ARE YOUR PLANS TO BUILD IN
THE KIND OF OVERSIGHT.
ACCOUNTABILITY IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHAT YOU INTEND WHAT I HEAR
YOU SAY YOU INTEND TO BUILD.
GETS BUILT IN A WAY THAT TAKES
INTO ACCOUNT THE HISTORICAL.
.
DISPROPORTIONATE AND NEGATIVE
EXPERIENCES BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND SOME
COMMUNITIES.
THE KIDS OF COLOR AND KIDS FROM
CERTAIN BACKGROUNDS
WHAT WILL WE DO TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS DOESN'T OPEN THE DOOR.
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS POLICE
OFFICERS TO.
CRIMINALIZE KIDS MYSTERY KIDS
ARM IN THE WAYS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED IN SOME SITUATIONS.
WELL FIRST WORDS A LOOK I I
WANNA. SIT DOWN WITH PEOPLE WHO
HAVE CONCERNS ENGAGE WITH THEM
AND HEAR WHAT THEY'RE. WHAT
THEY'RE DIFFERENT IDEAS ARE?
OPEN YOU KNOW TWO SUGGESTIONS
ON HOW WE ENSURE THAT AND AND
HOW WE BUILD IN THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY MECHANISM ON THAT
OR. IS THERE MAY BE SOME
ADDITIONAL TRAINING.
.
KNOW AT THIS POINT A TIME WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS ONE.
ONE SRO THAT PER CAMPUS RIGHT
NOW I'M SO WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT MULTIPLE. PEOPLE.
DOOR TALKING AT LEAST ONE
PERSON.
AND YOU LOOK WITH AS WE MOVE
FORWARD I WILL CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
AND I'M OPEN TO TO DIFFERENT
IDEAS ABOUT HOW WE HOW WE DO
THAT I'LL BE LOOKING FOR THAT I
THINK THERE HAS TO BE.
THAT LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT.
IN ACCOUNTABILITY.
SO THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE THE
TRUST IN THE FAITH AT THIS TO
WORK CAN NO THERE ARE
STRUCTURES.
TO HELP IT TO WORK NOW IF THEY
WERE IF IT WORKS IT WORKS
IN WHAT I HOPE HAPPENS THIS
STRONG RELATIONSHIPS GET BUILT.
MY CAN COMMUNITY POLICING WERE
STRONG RELATIONSHIPS GET BUILT
BUT UNTIL THAT HAPPENS I THINK
THERE'S A FAIR EXPECTATION THAT
THERE SHOULD BE BUILT IN
STRUCTURES.
TO ENSURE THAT THERE ARE OVER
SITES TO PROTECT AGAINST
ABUSE MISUSE THAT RESULTED OF
CRIMINALIZATION OF CHILDREN. THE
MISTREATMENT OF CHILDREN OR THE
HARM OF CHILDREN.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE FOR MY
OWN CLASSROOM EXPERIENCE I HAVE
NOT SEEN THE OFFICERS AROUND
CAMP.
ENGAGE IN STUDENT DISCIPLINE.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S YOUR GOAL
EITHER I APPRECIATE MR BEHRENS
COMMENTS WITH ME ABOUT WE BUILD
THAT WALL.
STATUTORILY I DON'T KNOW BUT I
IN APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
GOING FORWARD. AND I ALSO THINK
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
AN OFFICE ON CAMPUS AND BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS.
WITH STUDENTS ARE A SO THAT
THERE IS THAT TRUST.
GAIN OR REGAIN SO I APPRECIATE
WHERE WERE ALL OF US ARE COMING
FROM WITH THAT.
YOU MAY CLOSE ALRIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME ON THIS NOW TO SET
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE GREAT. THANK YOU
COULD YOU COULD SECRETARY PLEASE
PLUS W. OR.
O'DONNELL HERE.
KILEY THEIR.
KALRA.
THEY KEEP LACKEY THEIR.
MCCARTY.
THURMOND.
WEBER.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SO WITH
THAT.
.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED AND I SORT OF.
REITERATE THERE ARE THERE ARE
TWO AMENDMENTS REMOVE THE
REFERENCES TO ARMED SECURITY
GUARDS SO WE WANT A FULL PEACE
OFFICER RIGHT ARE ON ON CAMPUS.
AND INCLUDE CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
THE REQUIREMENTS HAVE AN ARMED
PEACE OFFICER ON.
CAMPUS THE BILL'S REMOVED AND
SECOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL AYE.
O'DONNELL I KILEY. KILEY AYE
LACKEY.
YEAH I KALRA.
MCCARTY THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WEBER.
FOUR VOTES TO THOSE OF THE BILL
AS IT HAS FOR VOTES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
PATTERSON.
THAT WE'RE GONNA MISS A GONZALEZ
FLETCHER ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
AND YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS A.
B. NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR WOULD
PREVENT SCHOOL DISTRICT FROM
TAKING PUNITIVE ACTION AGAINST A
STUDENT FOR HAVING DEBT TO THE
SCHOOL. AND FROM USING A DEBT
COLLECTOR WHEN ATTEMPTING
COLLECT DEBT OWNED BY A PARENT
OR GUARDIAN.
INCREASINGLY FAMILIES EXPECTED
PAY MORE OUT OF THEIR POCKETS IN
ORDER FOR THEIR CHILDREN TO
PARTICIPATE IN SCHOOL. WHEN
FAMILIES LACK THE RESOURCES TO
TOOK PUNITIVE MEASURES AGAINST
STUDENTS FOR DEBT THAT THEY HAVE
LITTLE CONTROL OVER.
DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN KNOWN TO
DENY HONOR CERTIFICATES
TRANSCRIPTS AND DIPLOMAS
PARTICIPATION GRADUATION
CEREMONIES AND PARTICIPATION IN
FIELD TRIPS.
THESE EXCLUSIONS ULTIMATELY
RESULT IN DIFFERENTIAL TREATMENT
WHICH CAN AFFECT A SINCE
ACADEMIC EXPERIENCE BETTER
SOCIAL WELL BEING.
IN ONE EXAMPLE OF ACTION TAKEN
AGAINST A STUDENT A CHARTER
SCHOOL IN EAST OAKLAND WOULD
PROVIDE HONORABLE STUDENTS A
CERTIFICATE THAT INCLUDED A
WATER MARK THAT READ DEBT OWED
IF THEIR PARENT OWED EVEN THE
SMALLEST AMOUNT OF MONEY.
IN ADDITION TO TAKING ACTION
AGAINST PUPILS SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS HAVE TURNED. TO
SENDING FAMILIES TO DEBT
COLLECTORS WHICH WILL FOREVER
AFFECT THEIR CREDIT RATING.
THAT WAS HAPPENING IN SAN DIEGO
ALTHOUGH I WILL SAY THAT THE SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
HAS SINCE STOPPED THAT ACTION
AND HAVE.
VOTED TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THIS IS SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE IN
THOSE ACTIONS ONLY PERPETUATE A
FAMILY'S FINANCIAL DIFFICULTIES.
WHEN PARENTS LACK THE RESOURCES
TO PAY SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS TO
WORK COOPERATIVELY WITH PARENTS
RATHER THAN ACT LIKE A LOAN
PROVIDER IN SENDING FAMILIES TO
COLLECTIONS.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY I HAVE
A COUPLE WITNESSES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE SOLVE
OUR VINCE HE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND CALIFORNIA AND WERE PLEASE
TO SPONSOR THIS BILL.
CALIFORNIA'S CONSTITUTION
GUARANTEES EVERY CHILD A FREE
PUBLIC EDUCATION BUT ASK ANY
PARENT IN CALIFORNIA THEY WILL
TELL YOU THAT PUBLIC SCHOOL
ATTENDANCE IS OFTEN ANYTHING BUT
FREE. FROM BUS RIDES TO UNIFORMS
TO SCHOOL SUPPLIES TO LOSS BOOKS
PARENTS WHO LACK THE RESOURCES
TO KEEP UP WITH THE BILLS ARE
HAVE INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES TO
GO INTO DEBT WITH THE SCHOOL.
NO CHILD SHOULD BE BURDEN FROM
BECAUSE OF THEIR PARENTS UNPAID
SCHOOL ME.
SCHOOL THAT.
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS TAKE
DIRECT ACTION AGAINST THE
STUDENT WHEN THE PARENT
STAFF
DID NINE TRANSCRIPTS OR FOR
CERTIFICATES DENYING ACCESS TO
THE LIBRARY. BENNY PARTICIPATION
IN THE GRADUATION CEREMONY OR
ACCESS TO FIELD TRIPS.
FOR INSTANCE AN ADVOCATE SHARED
STORY OF MARIO A STUDENT SAN
DIEGO WHO'D BEEN IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION FOR MOST OF THE
SCHOOLING BEFORE GOING INTO A
TRADITIONAL CLASSROOM FOR HIS
SENIOR YEAR. HE WAS EXCITED
ABOUT HIS GRADUATION CEREMONY
AND THEN GOT A SENIOR DEBT LIST
A WEEK BEFORE THE CEREMONY THAT
LIST A MISSING FOURTH GRADE
BOOK.
IN THE SCHOOL TOLD HIM THAT HE
COULDN'T PARTICIPATE IN THE
CEREMONY UNLESS HE PAID THOSE
STATS HE WAS HEARTBROKEN.
BECAUSE IT WORKS SO HARD TO GET
THERE.
CHILDREN SHOULD SIMPLY NOT BE
USED AS A TOOL FOR GOT
COLLECTION OR SHAMED OR
MARGINALIZED FROM SCHOOL
ACTIVITIES BECAUSE OF HER
PARENTS INABILITY OR
UNWILLINGNESS TO PAY IT THAT.
THAT ADVERSE ACTION TOWARD
STUDENTS CONTRIBUTES TO AN
HOSTILE ENVIRONMENT FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS.
FURTHERMORE THIRD PARTY DEBT
COLLECTION FOR SCHOOL DEBTS MAY
ACTUALLY VIOLATE CHILD PRIVACY
LAWS.
THE FAMILY EDUCATION RIGHTS AND
PRIVACY ACT PURPOSE. GENERALLY
PROHIBITS SCHOOLS FROM SHARING
INFORMATION ABOUT ABOUT CHILDREN
WITHOUT RID WRITTEN CONSENT
IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICT SHARING A STUDENTS
INFORMATION WITH A THIRD PARTY
DEBT COLLECTOR. ACTUALLY
COMPLIES WITH FOR ABOUT.
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR WILL
PREVENT CHILDREN FROM BEING
BROUGHT INTO THE PRIVATE DEBT
PAYMENT ARRANGEMENTS BETWEEN THE
SCHOOL AND A PARENT OR GUARDIAN.
THE BILL DOESN'T REQUIRE THAT
SCHOOLS ABSORB ALL OF THE DAY
UNPAID FEES OR STOP COLLECTING
DATA.
IT SIMPLY PROHIBIT SCHOOLS FROM
USING CHILDREN. AS A AS A MEANS
TO COLLECT THOSE DEBTS OR
SHARING INFORMATION ABOUT THAT
CHILD WITH THIRD PARTY DEBT
COLLECTORS.
OUR CHILDREN SHOULD NOT BE USES
IT AS TOOLS FOR DEBT COLLECTION
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHY SURE FOR
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA.
THE RIGHT TO A FREE EDUCATION IS
ENSHRINED IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. THAT RIGHT IS NOT
CONTINGENT ON THE STUDENTS OR
FAMILY'S ABILITY TO PAY FEES.
DENYING A STUDENT THE ABILITY TO
RECEIVE GRADES ARE TRANSCRIPTS
TO TAKE PART OF SCHOOL
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS FIELD TRIPS
OR EVEN TO PARTICIPATE IN
GRADUATION CEREMONY BECAUSE THE
FAMILY HAS UNPAID FEES IS QUITE
SIMPLY A DENIAL OF THAT
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
SUCH ACTIONS ARE ALSO
FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR TO LOW
INCOME STUDENTS WHO AREBURDENED
WITH BOTH THE SHAME OF HAVING
THEIR PEERS KNOW ABOUT THEIR
STRUGGLES. BECAUSE ALL OF THE
STEPS ARE THINGS THAT OTHER
STUDENTS ARE EASILY GOING TO BE
ABLE TO OBSERVE. AND BARRIERS TO
GETTING THE EDUCATION THEY
DESERVE WHEN THE SCHOOLS TAKE
ACTION AGAINST THEM BECAUSE OF
THE FAMILY'S UNPAID FEES.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
COMMITTED TO EQUITY IN ITS
SYSTEM OF PUBLIC EDUCATION BUT A
SCHOOL TAKING NEGATIVE ACTION
AGAINST A STUDENT BECAUSE THE
PARENTS HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO PAY
FEES IS NOT EQUITABLE. IT HARM
STUDENTS FROM LOWER INCOME
FAMILIES WHILE STUDENTS FROM
HIGHER INCOMES FAMILIES HAVE
NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT.
TO PRESERVE THE RIGHT OF ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS TO A FREE
EDUCATION AND TO PROTECT
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY IN OUR STATE
WE ASK THAT YOU VOTE YES ON AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU THE CLARIFY THE
AMENDMENTS HONOR THE EGGS OF THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS FOR DEBT OWED
DUE TO VANDALISM.
OR LOS WILFUL DAMAGE TO SCHOOL
PROPERTY.
THOSE ARE THE ONES WE DISCUSSED
TODAY.
THOSE AMENDMENTS WE DISCOVERED
LATER TODAY I I WOULD LIKE TO.
WE WILL NOT RENEGOTIATE THEM
NOW.
THAT'S FINE NOT IT'S I I KNOW
YOU WANT YOU WANT TO WORK ON
THIS BILL FURTHER I KNOW THE
YOUR I ONE OF OUR MOTHERS WILL
FURTHER I WANT TO CLARIFY ONE
THING THAT I WAS CONCERNED WITH.
VANDALISM YES WILLFUL.
LOSS YES BUT I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT HOMELESS STUDENTS WHO MAY
LOSE TEXTBOOKS BECAUSE OF
DISPLACEMENT OF THEIR OWN WHEN
WE DO THIS WHEN WE HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT. YEAH
I'M AND THAT'S WHAT I DON'T
THINK IT'S HARD TO GET. TO KNOW
TO EXACTLY I THINK IT'S A VERY
SMALL.
PERCENTAGE BUT WE HAVE NO
RECORD NINE TO SEE IF THERE WAS
SOME CONVERSATION HAD TODAY WAS
LIKE THIS IS PRETTY NAILED DOWN
NO IT IS ONLY NOW DOWN TO BE
GOING BACK ON THAT PATH YOU
KNOW.
THESE SMALL AYE AYE AYE AYE I
DON'T.
UNFORTUNATELY THINK FIRST OF A
HOMELESS STUDENT WHO MAYBE GETS
DISPLACED SIX TIMES DURING A
SCHOOL THAT IS A LEGITIMATE
CONCERN SOAPS AWAY WILL
CONTEMPLATE THAT'S WILL
CONTEMPLATE THAT ACCEPT
AMENDMENTS HAS RIGHT NOW.
BINGO THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. OF MY CARE
WITH WESTERN CENTER LAW POVERTY
IN SUPPORT OF.
LARA PRESIDENT OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS I'M WITH THE
AMENDMENT STATES AS I THINK I
UNDERSTAND THEM.
WE ARE ABLE TO SUPPORT.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
IN SUPPORT THOUGH.
SHUT OFF.
IT I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
KNOW THAT I DO HAVE SOME FURTHER
IN SUPPORT YES OKAY COUNTY
QUICKLY DANIELLE CANNOT KAISER
ON BEHALF OF COMMON SENSE KIDS
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT THINK.
SAY NO THERE'S IN SUPPORT AGAIN
APPEARED HERE IN SUPPORT. OF
THESE LOSE BROWN JUNIOR ON
BEHALF OF POLICY MAKING THE
LINES FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
OKAY AYE THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN CLIFF
WE'RE HERE WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLECTORS.
I HAVE TO SAY MY CLIENT IS
SYMPATHETIC TO THE INTENT OF THE
AUTHOR AND TO MOST OF THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL. ARM AND
WE'RE IN CONVERSATION WORKING
WITH HER ON TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
THE RIGHT APPROACH. CURRENTLY IS
THE IS THE BILL IS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN A CONTAINS A COMPLETE.
BAN ON A SCHOOL JUST YOUR SCHOOL
CONTRACTING WITH A COLLECTION
AGENCY WE THINK THAT IS OVER
BROAD AND IS NOT EXACTLY THE
RIGHT APPROACH YOU KNOW. LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR IN TRYING TO DRILL DOWN
I'M REALLY FOCUSING ON WHAT
AREAS ARE A PROBLEM BUT.
THE APPROACH OF.
IN ESSENCE COOLEY BANNING A
RELATIONSHIP WITH WILL LEGAL
BUSINESSES WHEN CERTAIN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO DO THAT. AS WELL AS
FULL IN THE NEED TO FOCUS ON
SPECIFIC.
PROBLEM AREAS I THINK.
WE'RE CERTAINLY SYMPATHETIC TO
PROTECT.
NEW RESEARCH PROBLEMATIC
PRACTICES BUT AT THIS TIME WE
ARE OPPOSED.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION SARAH
BOTCHES WITH KASBAH WE HAD AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED DUE TO THE
CONVERSATION THAT TOOK PLACE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO IT RECONSIDERING OUR
POSITION.
SINGLE MOTHERS FURTHER
OPPOSITION.
BEHIND THE RAIL ANY COMMENTS.
MR MCCARTY SURE I'D CAME IN A
BIT LATE BUT I I SUPPORT THE
BELT MOVE THE BILL RIGHT NOW.
BEGIN WITH THE MEMBER I DO HAVE
A QUESTION FOR YOU SO. I I THINK
IT'S IT'S UP I THINK THE BELIEF
OF MANY OF US THAT WE DON'T WANT
TO.
PENALIZE BEING POOR THAT'S WHY
WE DID THAT YOU KNOW THAT
SHAMING FOR SCHOOL LUNCHES LAST
YEAR. AND IN THIS BILL IN THE
STORIES THAT YOU YOU BRING UP
FROM YOUR.
ON AREAS SAN DIEGO.
I THINK PROVIDERS POWERFUL
EXAMPLES THAT WE DON'T HAVE YOU
KNOW HARM PEOPLE CORRECTIVE FOR
FOR BEING POOR.
BUT YEAH  THAT THERE ARE
HYPOTHETICALS AND I KNOW WE'RE
STILL WORKING ON THIS WHERE.
YET MAYBE INDIVIDUAL.
THAT JUST DOESN'T WANT TO PAY
THEIR AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM AND
THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY.
A INCOME BRACKET WERE YOU KNOW
POVERTY RISES THAT MAYBE THERE
ARE SOME OUT LIARS AND SO ARE
THERE ANY EXAMPLES WHERE WE'RE
COLLECTION WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
POTENTIALLY.
FOR IT FOR A SCHOOL DISTRICT.
INSIDE JUST WANT TO YOU KNOW
ASK YOU YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT.
I UNDERSTAND AND I'VE HEARD
HYPOTHETICALS ABOUT STUDENTS AND
DRONES AND RICH AREAS IN PARENTS
NOT WANTING TO PAY FOR.
DRUMS WHICH I DIDN'T KNOW WERE
BEING USED BY SCHOOLS.
AS FAR AS AN AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM AND AND.
THAT COULD BE UNIQUE IN NOT
SOMETHING WE WANT TO WORK ON.
OFTEN.
.
SOMETIMES IT'S A THIRD PARTY
OPERATING THAT AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM AND SO THE THIRD PARTY
MIGHT HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE PARENT.
SEPARATELY CONTRACTUAL
RELATIONSHIP THAT THEY COULD
STILL PURSUE. IF IT'S BEING DONE
THROUGH THE SCHOOL BY ALL MEANS
A SCHOOL COULD AND IT'S AN AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM I I THINK WE DID
INTEND TO SAY THAT. THAT
CHILDREN WHO OTHERWISE COULDN'T
QUALIFY FOR FOR FREE OR REDUCED
PRICES COULD CONTINUE TO ATTEND
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS WITHOUT
PAIN.
THOSE THOSE ARE USUALLY
STRUCTURED IN A WAY THAT YOU GET
BILL DINNER AND A SYSTEMATIC.
TIME FRAME AND IF YOU.
OUR CONTINUED IF YOU'RE NOT
PAYING YOUR BILL COULD NOT
UTILIZE SOMETHING THAT IS EXTRA
BEYOND THE SCHOOL DAY. I'M SO I
THINK THAT THERE ARE OTHER TOOLS
AVAILABLE MY CONCERN IS.
IS WRITING HUGE EXEMPTIONS
RIGHT BECAUSE. YOU KNOW WE
STARTED THIS WITH WITH THE FACT
THAT.
DEBT COLLECTORS WERE BEING USED
AND FOUND OUT LATER BY A SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT THE THEY WERE
ACTUALLY GETTING BACK. AND THEY
WERE LOSING MONEY USING A DEBT
COLLECTOR IT WAS THE THREAT OF
THE QUESTION AND IN MEANTIME
RUNNING PEOPLE'S CREDIT NAM. AND
THOSE WERE MAINLY.
MIDDLE CLASS OR MIDDLE CLASS
STUDENTS TO A MAIN I'VE BEEN
FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH PROGRAM
BEGINNING YEAR AND THEN BECOME.
APPARENTLY IS IS A JOB OR HAS A
DIFFERENT SITUATION.
SO I IF THERE'S SPECIFIC THINGS
THAT WE CAN RIDE INTO PROTECT.
.
TO PROTECT SCHOOLS FROM RICH
PARENTS WHO JUST DON'T WANNA PAY
BILLS ARE MORE THAN HAPPY TO DO
THAT I KNOW AND TENSION DID I
HAVE.
YOU KNOW.
AS A BILL TO ALLOW.
PEOPLE TO CIRCUMVENT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY.
SO WERE MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU HAVE SOME IDEAS ON
THAT.
THANK YOU AND MAYBE THE PLACE TO
GO IS HAVE THE STATE BACK FROM
THOSE DOLLARS ASSOCIATE WITH THE
LOS.
IF WE'RE SAYING YOU CAN'T
COLLECT ON THAT. AND AGAIN FOR
FREE REDUCED AYE AYE THEY ARE
PROBABLY ALREADY EXEMPT MANY
CASES YEAH.
SO DOES A CONVERSATIONS WE CAN
HAVE DOWN THERE ARE RATHER THAN
HAVING A SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICER
AT EVERY SCHOOL. THAT'S A
DIFFERENT BILL I DIDN'T SEE YOU
CAN ASK.
I DON'T KNOW THAT SEEMS REALLY
EXPENSIVE TO I THINK I WAS A CO
AUTHOR.
BUT I'M MISTER BECAUSE THAT THE
REPORTER FROM THE APPROACH HERE.
YOU KILEY HANNAH.
I'M SURE MANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY BACK TO BACK TO THIS BILL
I'M SAID THE CHAIR I HAD JUST
DIED ACTION BROUGHT UP THE POINT
I WAS GOING TO RAISE.
LOOKING AT THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS LOOKS LIKE.
LOCATE INCOME.
FAMILIES ARE ALREADY EXEMPT
FROM A LOT OF THESE FEES SO I'D
WHY IS THIS BILL NECESSARILY A
PRIORITY AND.
THE AUTHOR FOR THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WHEN.
IT'S NOT JUST THE PEACE FIRST OF
ALL AND AND.
TICKETS TO BE.
CLEAR IT'S NOT JUST FEES ADD IN
WERE TALKING IN SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT BY SEEN YES ON ON BY SEEN
FREE AND REDUCED.
LUNCH SOME CHILDREN WHO FALL
UNDER THAT CATEGORY OFTEN ARE
COVERED BUT YOU HAVE SITUATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. THAT.
A CHILD TO ME START OFF THE
YEAR ANY.
WITH PARENTS IN A FINANCIAL
POSITION WHERE THEY ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO THAT THINGS CAN
CHANGE.
AND WE SEE THAT A LOT.
SITUATIONS CHANGE.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST THE BY SEEN
ASPECT THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE WERE ALSO TALKING ABOUT
THINGS LIKE STAMP GREEN AYE AYE
CHILD'S AYE DIPLOMA ARE NOT
GIVING EACH HOW DIPLOMA BECAUSE
OF THE DEBTS OF THEIR PARENTS.
THERE SOMETHING FUNDAMENTALLY
UNFAIR ABOUT THAT IT IS NOT THE
CHILD'S FAULT WE SHOULD NOT
PENALIZE A CHILD.
FOR HAVING AYE IN SITUATIONS
WHERE THEY'RE THEIR PARENTS ARE
NOT POOR.
HAVING HAVING PARENTS WERE
UNWILLING TO PAY FOR SOMETHING
IN EDUCATION IS SUPPOSED TO BE
FREE. AND SO WE JUST WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THE CHILD IS LEFT
HARMLESS.
IN ANY KIND OF SITUATION BY
WHICH THE PARENTS RESPONSIBLE
THAT'S WHY WE ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENT ON THINGS LIKE
VANDALIZE SCHOOL BOOKS RIGHT
THAT IS A SITUATION.
BY WHICH MOST OF THE TIME AT THE
CHILD IS NOT THE PART OF THE
CHILD IS IN FACT.
THE PERSON WHO COSTS.
FOR THAT KIND OF THE THE OTHER
PART OF THE.
THE DECK
DO KNOWN PRACTICE WHAT WHAT
USUALLY HAPPENS HOW SCHOOLS ARE.
IS THAT ARE THEY ARE MOST THEN
USING THAT COLLECTORS ARE TO.
I HAVE
SO. WE FOUND WHEN WE FIRST
STARTED THAT MOST WERE NOT USING
DEBT COLLECTORS IN AND SAN DIEGO
WAS A.
UNUSUAL CIRCUMSTANCE AND HAVE
SENT STANDING UPRIGHT HAS SINCE
STOPPED THAT PRACTICE.
HOWEVER I IN FURTHER REVIEW IN
FACT MEETING WITH THE OPPONENTS
AND WE FOUND THAT IN FACT
SOME RURAL SCHOOLS USE THAT KIND
OF CONTRACT WITH DEBT COLLECTORS
IN THE PROCESS OF DOING THEIR
NORMAL.
JUST COLLECTION OF ACCOUNTS
RECEIVABLE SO THAT'S WHAT HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT HAVING TO DEAL
WITH.
TO USE A THIRD PARTY YOU
OUTSOURCE.
COLLECTING JUST LIKE THINGS
THAT.
ARE RIGHTFULLY BEING CHARGED.
AND WE WON ENSURE.
THAT THAT COULD BE DONE IN A
WAY THAT THAT DOESN'T VIOLATE
FEDERAL LAW.
BUT ALSO DOESN'T PUT PEOPLE'S.
.
CREDIT AT JEOPARDY.
CREDIT SCORE.
I SEE SO THAT'S AN ALTERNATIVE
YOU'D ACTUALLY.
THE OPEN TO.
IF WE CAN DO IT WHERE DOESN'T
VIOLATE FEDERAL LAW WHERE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS SIMPLY.
I I HATE THAT THERE OUTSOURCING
BUT THEY HAVE TO CONTRACT WITH A
THIRD PARTY IN ORDER TO DO KIND
OF THE ACCOUNTS RECEIVABLE AT A
SCHOOL THAT IS NOT WHAT I'M
TRYING TO PREVENT SO WHAT THAT
OFTEN THAT.
COPYRIGHT.
WISE ONE OKAY AND OTHER NON.
THE ACTINS OF A DEBT WELL WHAT
WAS HAPPENING IN SAN DIEGO WAS A
TRADITIONAL DEBT COLLECTION
SITUATION WHERE THEIR CONTRACT
AFTER TRYING TO. RECEIVE THE
PAYMENT FROM THE PARENT.
THEY SENT IT TO A DEBT
COLLECTOR I'VE SOLD IT FOR
PENNIES ON THE DOLLAR THEY IN
FACT LOST MONEY BY DOING THIS
AND.
AND AS A RESULT THE DEBT
COLLECTORS WORKED.
ARE.
I DON'T WANNA OFFEND ANYONE'S
BUSINESS BUT.
.
I PURSUED THE DEBT.
IN A WAY THAT'S TRADITIONAL LIKE
ANY OTHER DEBT IN EVENTUALLY
LEADING TO PEOPLE'S AYE CREDIT
SCORE BEING RENT.
SO YOU IT SEEMS LIKE THE CONCERN
IS WITH THE CREDIT MOSTLY ON AND
YOUR AND.
THAT WILL TAKE A HIT IF YOU GO
TO REGISTER OFFICIAL DEBT
COLLECTOR BUT SOME OF THE THIRD
PARTY WHOSE.
ACTUALLY COLLECTING THAT'S MAYBE
THAT WON'T HAPPEN WHAT EVEN THE
SCHOOLS DO WRITE A SCHOOL
DOESN'T JUST SEND YOU KNOW YOUR
YOUR THEY HAVE A FORM OF OF
ALERTING PARENTS THAT YOU OWE
SOMETHING RIGHT. AND SOME
SCHOOLS YOU NOW AND I'VE.
FORGOTTEN TO PAY SOMETHING ONCE
AND GOTTEN SIXTEEN EMAILS FROM
THE SPORTS I COME IN AND PAY IT
MOUNTS NORMAL ACTIVITY THAT
HAPPENS I THINK IT'S SCHOOLS
AND.
OBVIOUSLY IF YOU'RE LARGE ENOUGH
SCHOOL. YOU KNOW YOU YOU CAN
PROVIDE THAT WITHIN YOUR OWN
ACCOUNTING SYSTEM I I DO FEEL I
FEEL I I I UNDERSTAND IF IT'S A
SMALL WORLD SCHOOL ARE A SMALL
SCHOOL CAN'T PROVIDE FOR A
POSITION THAT DOES THAT THAT
THAT MIGHT BE NECESSARY.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE.
YEAH I GUESS SO I'M.
I'M.
STILL A LITTLE UNCLEAR AND I YOU
KNOW.
WHETHER YOU'RE IS CATEGORICALLY
OPPOSED TO THIS
TAKE YOUR INDUSTRY TO HAVING ANY
ROLE IN THE PROCESS BY WHICH
WOULD ALLOW FOR THIRD PARTIES
TO.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT IT A
BY WE ARE ABIDING BY FEDERAL LAW
FOR SO LONG YOU KNOW AND MAKING
SURE WE'RE NOT GIVING AWAY THAT
STUDENTS INFORMATION.
BUT I AM NOT OPPOSED TO PEOPLE
COLLECTING WHAT IS OWED I AM
OPPOSED TO ROUTINE.
YOU KNOW COAXES AS.
CREDIT SCORE ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHO ARE UNATTAINABLE SOLICIT
SITUATION AND ARE PAYING FOR
SOMETHING QUITE FRANKLY THAT I
THINK WE'RE DOING A DISSERVICE
TO MOST PARENTS BY NOT.
PROVIDING FOR FREE.
CAN I CAN I ASK WHAT YOU MAY NOT
KNOW THE ANSWER MAYBE THE
OPPOSITION URBAN
SUPPORTERS WILL NOT. IS IS
GOVERNMENT DEBT WHEN IT GOES TO
A COLLECTION AGENCY DOES IT
IMPACT YOUR CREDIT SCORE.
IT I THOUGHT ADDITIONALLY DOES
NOT THERE'S AN EXCEPTION BUT IT
WITH THAT IF YOU USE AN
INDEPENDENT LIKE THE BUS SERVICE
THAT IN SAN DIEGO IT DEAD SO
THAT THE PARENTS WHO SPOKE OUT.
NAKAI CLIPPER BACK.
I THINK THE ANSWER. WOULD BE
THAT YOU TO CLOSE THE KIND OF
GOVERNMENT DEBT SO THERE IS AN
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE NATIONAL
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S ASSOCIATION.
DEBT COLLECTION IN THE CREDIT
BUREAUS THAT CERTAIN TIE KINDS
OF GOVERNMENT DEBT SUCH AS
PENALTIES AND FEES ARE NOT
REPORTABLE. ARM ON CREDITS.
OTHER KINDS OF THAT ARE
ACTUALLY CONTRACTUAL.
AGREEMENTS
WERE YOU AGREED WITH A
GOVERNMENT AGENCY TO ACCEPT THE
SERVICE IN RETURN JUST LIKE ANY
NORMAL PRIVATE TRANSACTION WOULD
BE REPORTABLE I THINK HOWEVER IN
THE CASE OF.
ON THE SCHOOL DEBT SITUATION
THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING TO THE
AUTHOR ABOUTS NAM CERTAINLY WE
ARE WILLING TO WORK WITH HER IN
TRYING TO. ADDRESS HER CONCERNS
ABOUT CREDIT REPORTING OVER
THESE KINDS OF EDUCATION ALL
EXPENSES THAT BECAUSE
YOU KNOW CLEARLY FALL INTO THIS
CATEGORY OF AREAS OF EQUAL
EDUCATION.
AND PROTECTING STUDENTS
AND LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES FROM HAVING THEIR
CREDIT SCORES IN ANYWAY.
AFFECTED BY NORTON WHAT WOULD BE
NORMAL COLLECTION ACTIVITIES
EVEN THOSE CONTRACTUAL SO WE'RE
HOPING TO WORK WITH THEIR AND
I'M WRITING THE RIGHT LANGUAGE
TO COVER THE SITUATIONS IN THIS.
IN THIS INSTANCE BUT YEAH THERE
ARE BROAD LIMITS CERTAIN KINDS
OF GOVERNMENT DEBT IS.
REPORTABLE SOME SOME ISN'T I
WOULD ALSO JUST ADD JUST FOR THE
RECORD.
THE COLLECTION INDUSTRY WHICH
REPRESENTS BANKS AND HOSPITALS
AND DOCTORS
HOUSE TO ABIDE BY ALL OF THE
PRIVACY LAWS IN OUR COUNTRY
WHETHER IT'S HIP ARE. WHETHER
IT'S FINANCIAL PRIVACY AND THEY
CERTAINLY ARE GOING AGREE AND
IT'S PART OF THEIR YOU KNOW BOTH
LEGAL WORK RESPONSIBILITY IN
THAT WOULD BE SUED AT THE GAZOO
BUT THE VIOLATE ANYBODY'S
PRIVACY RIGHTS AND TO REJECT IN
THE EDUCATION AREA. THAT'S
COMPLY WITH ALL THAT IN THE IN
THE HEALTHCARE IN THE FINANCIAL
PRIVACY. AREAS SO CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO REASSURE THE AUTHOR OF
ANY KINDS OF NEED TO RESTATE
THAT.
THANK YOU.
ON SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENT.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
IT WOULD DO OKAY YEAH THE
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WAIT A SECOND WHO MOVED.
AND.
MISTER MCCURRY WELL SECOND.
OKAY OF MR THURMAN SECOND OKAY.
THAT THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL ARE. PUT ON AYE KILEY.
HOW THEY KNOW LACKEY?
KALRA.
CALLER AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY
AYE THURMOND.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
TWO BILLS FOR VOTERS OUT.
ALL RIGHT.
NEXT OVER TO MR NEWS AREA WHICH
HAS BEEN SITTING OUT THERE
PATIENTLY.
THE SMILE MAY COME UP.
PRESENT YOUR BILL IT'S.
.
AB TWENTY THREE NINETEEN A FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN FIFTEEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THAT
COLLEAGUES AND FOR THE SAKEOF.
THE COMMITTEE'S WORK AHEAD I'LL
I'LL KEEP IT VERY BRIEF.
AB TWENTY THREE NINETEEN WITH
DELETE THE TERM FOREIGN LANGUAGE
FROM THE EDUCATION CODE AND
REPLACE IT WITH THE TERM WORD
WELL WORLD LANGUAGE.
STRAIGHT FORWARD.
AS IT SOUNDS
WITH ME IS NICOLE AND THAT IT'S
A PROGRAM SPECIALIST THAT THE ST
ONE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
O'DONNELL IN MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE AS
HE SAID MY NAME IS MICHAEL NAY
DEBTS AND I AM SPEAKING TO YOU
TODAY AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
CALIFORNIA LANGUAGE TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND I WILL BE BRIEF.
WORLD LANGUAGE PROGRAMS PROVIDE
STUDENTS WITH LINGUISTIC AND
INTERCULTURAL KNOWLEDGE SKILLS
AND PROFICIENCIES NECESSARY TO
INTERACT WITH SPEAKERS OF OTHER
LANGUAGES. IN WAYS THAT
DEMONSTRATE THEIR READINESS FOR
LIFE WORK AND CITIZENSHIP IN OUR
DIVERSE EVOLVING AND
INTERCONNECTED SOCIETY. BUT IN
ED CODE AND OTHER OFFICIALS
STATE DOCUMENTS THESE PROGRAMS
ARE NOT DESIGNATED AS WORLD
LANGUAGE BUT AS FOREIGN LANGUAGE
AND THIS POSES DIFFICULTIES ON
NUMEROUS FRONTS.
FOR EXAMPLE THE WORD FOREIGN
OFTEN HAS A NEGATIVE CONNOTATION
THAT SETS ONE GROUP OF PEOPLE OR
OBJECTS
APART FROM OTHERS AS BEING
STRANGE. ALIEN DIFFERENT AND
UNFAMILIAR. AND THE FACT THAT
THESE FOUR TERMS ARE THE MOST
COMMON SYNONYMS OF THE WORD
FOREIGN PROVIDES COMPELLING
EVIDENCE THAT CLASSIFYING THE
STUDY OF LANGUAGES AS FOREIGN.
RISKS PROMOTING A CONNOTATION
THAT IS IN DIRECT CONTRAST TO
THE UNIFYING WORK WE DO S. WORLD
LANGUAGE EDUCATORS.
AND TO THE DISTINCT VALUE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S VAST LINGUISTIC AND
CULTURAL DIVERSITY BRINGS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR LOCAL AND
GLOBAL BUSINESS OPERATIONS.
AND IN FACT IN CALIFORNIA A
STATE THAT IS RICH IN DIVERSITY
NO LANGUAGES TRULY FOREIGN.
CHANGING ALL REFERENCES IN AT
CODE AND OFFICIAL DOCUMENTS TO
WORLD LANGUAGE SENDS A CLEAR
MESSAGE THAT OUR WEALTH OF
NATIVE AND ACQUIRED LANGUAGES
ARE AN ASSET. THAT SETS
CALIFORNIA APART AND CERTAINLY
NOT A FOREIGN PHENOMENON IN OUR
LINGUISTIC AND CULTURALLY
DIVERSE SOCIETY.
IN FACT AMERICAN SIGN LANGUAGE
AND THE NUMEROUS NATIVE AMERICAN
LANGUAGES SPOKEN IN CALIFORNIA
ARE ABSOLUTELY NOT FOREIGN. BUT
CURRENTLY THESE TRULY AMERICAN
LANGUAGES MUST BE CLASSIFIED AS
FOREIGN LANGUAGES DUE TO THE
WORDING CURRENTLY IN PLACE AN AD
CODE. AND FOR ALL OFFICIAL
EDUCATION DOCUMENTS.
IN ADDITION IT IS IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THAT FORTY TWO OF FIFTY
STATES HAVE ALREADY A RACE TO
THE TERM FOREIGN AND REPLACED IT
WITH THE TERM WORLD WHEN
REFERENCING COURSES OF STUDY
AIMED. AT LEARNING LANGUAGES
OTHER THAN ENGLISH.
THERE FOR IN THE STATE IN THE
SPIRIT OF INCLUSIVENESS AND ON
BEHALF OF OUR STUDENTS WORLD IN
WHICH PROGRAMS AND THE DIVERS
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITIES. WE APPROVED WE URGE
YOU TO APPROVE AB TWENTY THREE
NINETEEN AND ADOPT THE TERM
WORLD LANGUAGE THINKING.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MARTHA ZERO GOES IDEAS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER WE SUPPORT
THE BILL.
HOLLY HUNTER SPINOFFS ON BEHALF
OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TOM TOWARD
NIXON AND SUPPORT.
TEN IS THE COUNTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA LANGUAGE
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR SOME BROWN OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS ELECTION OF A LETTER
AND YET BECAUSE OUR CONVENTIONS
THIS WEEKEND BUT WE ANTICIPATE A
SUPPORT POSITION AFTER THAT
THANK YOU.
ISABEL GARCIA CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE'RE
RECOMMENDING A SUPPORTED OUR
STATE CONSTITUTION MANY.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO OPPOSITION.
.
IT BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED THAT
WE HAVE ECONOMY WILL SEE ANY
MIKLOS.
IN THE SPIRIT OF INCLUSIVENESS
ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
PLEASE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS.
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
O'DONNELL BY O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE THURMOND. THURMOND I
WEBER. WEBER AYE.
SIX GO TO BILLS OUT THANK YOU
MISS QUIRK SILVA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES ITEM
NUMBER TWO.
I AND NUMBER TWELVE AND NUMBER
TWELVE.
THEY BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR HEARING OUR BILL A.
B. TWO TWO SEVEN ONE. AND AS A
CLASSROOM TEACHER AND WATCHING
MY STUDENTS FOR MANY MANY YEARS
I EAT LUNCH. A THAT WE KNOW THAT
OVER THE YEARS. THAT OUR LUNCHES
OF CHANGE WE WENT FROM A.
SCHOOL SITES PREPARING MEALS ON
SITES EVEN CENTRAL KITCHENS
PREPARING MEALS TO NOW A MUCH OF
THE LUNCH I.
TYPES OF FOODS ARE PACKAGED IN
BROUGHT TO THE SCHOOLS SO MY
BILL WOULD HELP REDUCE FOOD
WASTE ON OUR K.. TWELVE SCHOOLS
BY EXPANDING EXISTING GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES ARE NOW AVAILABLE
THROUGH THE NATIONAL SCHOOL
LUNCH PROGRAM EQUIPMENT
ASSISTANCE GRANTS.
I BASICALLY THIS WHOLE OUT
SCHOOLS TO MATCH THEIR FUNDS
WITH THE NATIONAL SCHOOL LUNCH
TO BUY A LARGER EQUIPMENT SO
THEY COULD IN FACT START OUGHT
TO COOK. HEALTHIER MEALS NELSON
MIGHT STILL THAT'LL TAKE A QUITE
A BIT OF TIME IN ONE OF THE
DISTRICTS IN MY WAS.
DISTRICT CENTRALIA THEY
ACTUALLY ALREADY ARE DOING THIS
AND WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS
THEY'RE TAKING SOME OF THEIR
OLDER.
TYPES OF EQUIPMENT THAT THEY
PRETTY MUCH PUT AWAY IN THE LAST
DECADE BROUGHT IT OUT HAVE
PURCHASED SOME OTHER TYPES OF
LARGER COOKING EQUIPMENT TO
PRETTY MUCH PREPARE. OF FOOD ON
SITE THERE.
THEY NOW CALL THEIR COOK A CHEF
THEY SCHOOL CHEF WHICH WE HAVE
HEARD THAT I'M SURE BUT.
THOUGH THE OF A SHELF ON
BELIEVES IN WHAT HE'S DOING SO
MUCH THAT HE SAYS IS YOUNG
DAUGHTER ACTUALLY EATS THE FOOD
AND THEY TESTED OUT AT HOME.
HE'S ALSO TOLD US THAT ON SOME
OF THE PARENTS THEMSELVES HAVE
CALLED TO RECENT DATA. ASKS FOR
THE RECIPES BUT THIS STORY
REALLY RELATES NOT ONLY TO.
NOT WASTING FOOD BUT TO
CREATING HEALTHIER STUDENTS ON
OUR CAMPUS
SO WITH THAT I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
Q. ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT SEEN
OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION
SITTING ON A CONCERT BEHIND THE.
THE DICE.
TO KILEY.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MISS SOME I
SAW AYE AYES ONE EXTRA
UNDERSTANDING THIS THERE'S BEEN
WHAT A THREE MILLION DOLLAR.
POT OF MONEY THAT'S BECOME
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS TO APPLY FOR AND UP TO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR.
BLOCKS IS THAT RIGHT. WHAT
WOULD BE FOR A MATCHING GRANT SO
I AND YES BUT THAT THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS?
TO THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS IF THEY
ARE INTERESTED IN THIS TYPE OF
APPROACH.
SCHOOLS THAT ARE GETTING THAT
FEDERAL FUNDS EIGHT IS NOT GONNA
LIKE THE RICH GETTING RICHER
AND THE DAY THEY WE AREN'T
NECESSARILY GIVING THE FUNDS TO
THE SAME SCHOOLS AND IT'S UP TO
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT IF THEY WANT
TO APPLY BUT IF THEY THEY MAY.
ALREADY HAVE APPLIED AND HAVE
STARTED THIS PROCESS BUT IT
WOULD BE SO MAYBE MULTIPLE
SCHOOLS CAN JOIN TOGETHER OUGHT
TO HAVE A CENTRAL TYPE OF
KITCHEN THAT'S ONE WAY TO LOOK
AT IT PUTTING THEIR MONEY.
TOGETHER.
.
BUT YES IT IS A IT IT WOULD BE
JOINING THE FEDERAL DOLLARS WITH
THE STATE DOLLARS SO THEY CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE ENOUGH. ON IT TO
PUT TOGETHER TO IN ESSENCE BUILD
SOME TYPE OF CENTRAL KITCHEN AND
WE USE TO HAVE THOSE IN MOST OF
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS. MOST OF
THOSE WERE CLOSED DOWN.
NOT AFFECT MY MOTHER USED TO
WORK CAN ONE OF THE CENTRAL
KITCHENS AND THAT'S WHERE THEY
ACTUALLY PREPARED FOOD LIKE.
POTATOES BOILED THEM AND MADE
MASHED POTATOES VERSES USING
PROCESSED
FOOD.
WELL I MEAN I YEAH I I DON'T OF
DATA YOU KNOW I OBJECT TO THAT.
IDEAS AND THINGS COULD BE A
REALLY GOOD THING FOR DISTRICTS
I WAS WONDERING CUT OF WHY IS
THAT YOU KNOW IS A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS NOT ENOUGH IS.
TWO IF YOU THINK ABOUT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA EVEN IF FOUR FIVE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS APPLIED FOR
THAT THAT STILL VERY LIMITED TO
REALLY START. KIND OF A AYE
PILOT THAT COULD TAKE OFF AND
ENCOURAGE OTHERS SO THIS IS IN
ESSENCE A MATCHING FUNDS.
OKAY I GUESS I JUST LIKE TO SEE
A LITTLE BIT MORE. INFORMATION
ON.
YOU CAN GET YOU ARE NOT
AGRICULTURE DECIDED TO SET THE
LIMITS OF A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS SO WHY. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE THE WINNING PANIC
APPLICATIONS AND THEN AUGMENT
THAT MONEY RATHER TRY TO CREATE
A MORE WIDELY.
.
DISTRIBUTED BENEFIT.
WELL IF YOU THINK ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IT'S
STILL IF YOU'RE TRYING TO BUT TO
BRING BACK WHAT YOU WOULD CALL A
CENTRAL TYPE OF KITCHEN. AND YOU
LOOK AT DIFFERENT TYPE OF
EQUIPMENT THAT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS DEPENDING ON HOW LARGE
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT IS. ON THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT I WORK IN HAS
FIFTEEN SCHOOLS IF YOU THINK
ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER FIFTEEN SCHOOLS. THAT'S.
CAN THOUSAND DOLLARS YOU MIGHT
GET A BIG OF AN FOR THAT.
SO ALL THE OTHER THINGS THAT GO
ALONG WITH THE COOKING UP A
WORKING KITCHEN.
THANK YOU SEE NO OTHER COMMENTS.
.
YOU MAKE CLOSED WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THIS YEAR.
WE DID A HERE WE HAVE A MOTION.
SO YOU MAY CLOSE.
I JUST WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOUR MOTION IS.
.
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WHOSE
CULTURAL.
O'DONNELL UP BY O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY. AYE THE NO LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I THURMOND. THURMOND I
WEBER. WEBER AYE.
THE SIXTY ONE OF BILLS OUT THANK
YOU THINK YOU MEMBERS NEXT WORDS
KELLY RO I DON'T SEE THIS YEAR'S
WRITTEN.
I FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE.
YEAH I'LL AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
ONE FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THINK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY.
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE WILL
SIMPLY ADD MIGRANT STUDENTS TO
EXISTING LAW. SO THAT THEY CAN
RECEIVE PARTIAL OR FULL CREDIT
FOR WORK COMPLETED IN IT IN
ANOTHER SCHOOL. AND BE EXEMPT
FROM LOCAL COURSEWORK
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE EDITION
ALL TO STATE COURSEWORK
REQUIREMENTS IF A STUDENT CANNOT
REASONABLY. REASONABLY MEET THEM
IN THE TIME FOR HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION.
CURRENT LAW PROVIDES EACH RIGHT
STUDENTS IN FOSTER CARE THOSE
WHO ARE HOMELESS FORMER JUVENILE
COURT STUDENTS. OR CHILDREN OF
MILITARY FAMILIES
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN STUDENT
MOBILITY HAS NEGATIVE EFFECTS ON
STUDENT SUCCESS INCLUDING TEST
SCORES RETENTION AND HIGH SCHOOL
COMPLETION.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS LONG
RECOGNIZED THAT STUDENTS THAT
ARE REQUIRED TO MOVE REPEATEDLY
FACE MANY OBSTACLES TO HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION AND HAS PASSED
LEGISLATION TO ALLOW THEM TO
GRADUATE. YET COMPLETE IMPORTANT
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS
FRANKLY EXTENDING THESE RIGHTS.
TO MIGRANT STUDENTS IS LONG
OVERDUE.
MIGRANT STUDENTS ARE SOME OF THE
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS AND
FACE A GREATER RISK
MANY OF THEM DON'T HAVE.
PALOMA.
MANY OF THEM WERE LIMITED IN THE
TYPES OF EMPLOYMENT THEY COULD
OBTAIN.
AT THAT TIME.
THE ABSENCE OF A PROPOSED BY AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY OF TWENTY ONE
WERE NOT AVAILABLE.
THIS IS THE REASON WHY WE
SUPPORT AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE
IT IS PROPOSING TO EXEMPT
BUSINESS. PROPOSING TO PROVIDE
TO MIGRANT STUDENTS EXAMS
EXEMPTIONS FROM SPECIFIC LOCAL
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATIONS AND THE
ABILITY FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
US EXCEPT THE PARTIAL CREDIT.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS A FAIR BILL
WE BELIEVE THIS IS UNNECESSARY
BILL IF WE ARE TO SUPPORT OUR
MIGRANT STUDENTS IN PURSUING
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL. UP DIPLOMA
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER TO SUPPORT.
ERICA OFTEN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
I HAVE JUST BEEN OFF ON BEHALF
OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TOM TOWARD
EXTENT. UNFORTUNATELY WE WERE
UNABLE TO GET A LETTER IN TIME
BUT WE TO HAVE A SUPPORT
POSITION.
DANIEL KENDO BECAUSE OUR ON
BEHALF COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION
IN SUPPORT.
LARA PRESIDENT ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION
SING OPPOSITION NO COMMENTS RAY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MIKLOS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE VOTE
TO HAVE A MOTION.
IT'S REMOVED.
A SCAR AND SECOND MR MCCARTY
THE MOTION IS.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
O'DONNELL I. O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
LACKEY. LACKEY AYE KALRA. KALRA
AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE THURMAN.
THURMOND AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
ZERO. SIX ZERO THE VOTE THE BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WITH THAT.
WILL TURN TO MISTER GLORIA.
BEEN VERY PATIENT SMILING DOWN
THERE. YOU ME.
RECEIVING READING. AND NEXT WILL
GO TO MISTER THURMAN.
BECAUSE I DON'T SEE MISTER
BERMAN.
CAN AYE AND THEN WE'LL GO TO
DOCTOR WEBER AFTER THAT.
AND THEN ME.
SELECT PLANETS CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISS CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I WANT TO BEGIN THIS
AFTERNOON BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND WITH
APPRECIATION TO YOUR STAFF
WORKING WITH MINE. THAT'S
IMPROVE THIS BILL I AB TWENTY
NINE FORTY NINE INCREASES THE
EDUCATIONAL STABILITY OF
MILITARY CHILDREN IN OUR STATE.
ACCORDING TO US DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE CHILDREN OF MILITARY
FAMILIES CHANGE SCHOOLS KILLERS
UP TO NINE TIMES ON AVERAGE
BEFORE GRADUATING. THESE
CHILDREN ARE OFTEN FORCED TO
EXPERIENCE ADDITIONAL
UNNECESSARY SCHOOL CHANGES DUE
TO MILITARY HOUSING
AVAILABILITY.
A CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO FIFTY
SIX THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN MILITARY DEPENDENTS
ATTENDING K. TWELVE SCHOOLS IN
OUR STATE WITH A LARGE
CONCENTRATION NOT SURPRISE ME
DOCTOR WEBER NUYS DISTRICTS.
I KNOW WHAT NUMEROUS STUDIES
INDICATE THAT THE STUDENT
MOBILITY IS ASSOCIATED WITH POOR
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES HIGHER
DROPOUT RATES IN A WIDER
KNOWLEDGE GAP OF FOR THE
STUDENTS.
NOT TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AB
TWENTY NINE FORTY NINE GIVES OUR
SERVICE FAMILIES THE OPTION.
PLEADING ACADEMIC YEAR AT THEIR
SCHOOL ORIGIN DESPITE A CHANGE
IN RESIDENTS DURING THE SCHOOL
YEAR. THIS BILL ALSO PROVIDES
pCHILDREN WHOSE PARENTS MILITARY
STATUS CHANGED MID ACADEMIC
YEAR.
I IN THE CASE OF QUE.
TO TENTH GRADE STUDENTS THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO COMPLETE THE
SCHOOL YEAR AT THEIR CURRENT
SCHOOL AND FOR ELEVENTH AND
TWELFTH GRADE STUDENTS THEY
WOULD BE ALLOWED TO COMPLETE
THEIR EDUCATION GET THEIR
DIPLOMA. AT THEIR CURRENT SCHOOL
A BETWEEN AYE FORTY NINE
EMPOWERS LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
UNNECESSARY SCHOOL TRANSITIONS
FOR THESE OF IMPORTANT STUDENTS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY. AND WITH ME I HAVE ONE
WITNESS AT KELLY MADE WITH THE
RESULT WHOSETHE REGAL SCHOOL
LIAISON FOR UNITED STATES MARINE
CORPS INSTALLATIONS WES.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
.
MY NAME KELLY MAN I WORK FOR THE
MARINE CORPS I'M REPRESENTING
THE COMMANDING GENERAL FOR
MARINE CORPS INSTALLATIONS WEST
WHICH IS BASED AT MARINE CORPS
BASE CAMP PENDLETON.
WE ARE COVER SEVEN
INSTALLATIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OF THE THIRTY TWO
MILITARY INSTALLATIONS THAT ARE
HERE. WE ALSO HAVE APPROXIMATELY
SIXTEEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED.
MARINE CORPS CHILDREN OF ACTIVE
DUTY MARINES.
THAT ARE ATTENDING SCHOOL HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WITH SO MANY OF OUR CHILDREN
ATTENDING SCHOOL CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS DRINKER TAKES VERY
SERIOUSLY THE QUALITY OF.
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCES.
AND THEIR SUCCESS.
OUR STUDENTS MOVE EVERY THREE
YEARS TYPICALLY CAUSING THEM TO
ATTEND.
AN AVERAGE JUST SIX TO NINE
SCHOOLS BEFORE THEY GRADUATE.
AND THE REQUIRE WORKS VERY HARD
TO REDUCE THE NEGATIVE IMPACT OF
THE HIGH DEGREE OF.
TRANSITION ARM MARINE FAMILY
THINKER.
WHICH ARE OFTENTIMES VERY
NECESSARY FOR IT ON MISSION
REQUIREMENTS IN TRAINING. AND WE
HAVE A VARIETY OF POLICIES THAT
REDUCE MIDYEAR TRANSFERS AND
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT MILITARY
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN THROUGH
THEIR TRANSITIONS TO INCLUDE ON.
A PROGRAM CALLED THE SCHOOL
LIAISON PROGRAM.
ONE WAY THAT THE STATE CAN
CONTINUE TO ASSIST MILITARY
FAMILIES IS TO JOIN US IN
REDUCING MID YEAR SCHOOL
TRANSFERS THAT NOT ONLY HURTS
SCHOOLS THAT MUST ADJUST TO THE
FREQUENT TRANSITION.
OF THEIR POPULATION BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY.
.
CAN I HURT MILITARY CHILDREN AND
THEIR CIVILIAN PEERS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
I JACKSON WAS SENDING UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU
SEEN OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION SEEN OPPOSITION.
ANY COMMENTS FROM ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
.
SO YOU HAVE I'M WE HAVE TO HAVE
A MOTION.
KALRA AND THEN MISTER THERE IN
SECONDS.
AND THE MOTION IS.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO VETERANS
AFFAIRS THIS IS DOUBLE REFERRED.
TWO ANOTHER COMMITTING.
WITH THAT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL I O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE THURMOND. THURMOND
AYE WEBER. WEBER AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
THE SIXERS.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WILL GO TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB TO
SEE
THREE NINE BY MISTER BERMAN.
YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN READY STEVEN
RUNNING.
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN.
IT'S BERMAN AND O'DONNELL AS
RIGHT. DOWN RIGHT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THE FEDERAL CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL AND PREVENTION REPORTS
THAT SUICIDE AMONG ADOLESCENTS
AND YOUNG ADULTS IS ON THE RISE
NATIONALLY. AND IS NOW THE
SECOND LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH
AMONG YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULTS
AGED TEN TO TWENTY FOUR YEARS OF
AGE.
UNFORTUNATELY MY HOMETOWN OF
PAUL ALSO HAS EXPERIENCED TO
SUICIDE CLUSTERS.
ONE DURING THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT TWO THOUSAND NINE SCHOOL
YEAR AND THE OTHER DURING THE
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN TO FIFTEEN
SCHOOL YEAR WHICH RESULTED IN
TEN TRAGEDIES.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN CHAIR
O'DONNELL AUTHORED AB TWENTY TO
FORTY SIX
WHICH REQUIRES SCHOOLS TO ADOPT
POLICIES FOR THE PREVENTION OF
STUDENT SUICIDES. AND REQUIRES
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO DEVELOP AND
MAINTAIN A MODEL SUICIDE
PREVENTION POLICY.
BUILDING UPON THIS LEGISLATION
GIORDANO AND I HAVE JOINT
AUTHORED AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
NINE.
WHICH WOULD SUPPORT OUR EFFORT
OUR SCHOOLS EFFORTS TO IMPROVE
SUICIDE AWARENESS AND PREVENT
FURTHER TRAGEDIES BY OFFERING
ONLINE SUICIDE PREVENTION
TRAINING FOR ALL SCHOOL STAFF.
AS WELL AS STUDENTS.
AS THE COMMITTEE POINTS OUT IN
THE ANALYSIS NUMEROUS POLICY
DOCUMENTS ON SUICIDE PREVENTION
RECOMMEND THAT TEACHERS AND
OTHER SCHOOL STAFF. BE TRAINED
ON THIS TOPIC GENERALLY VIEWING
SCHOOL STAFF AS GATE KEEPERS
YOU CAN PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN
PREVENTING SUICIDE.
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY NINE WOULD
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
IDENTIFY EVIDENCE BASED ONLINE
SUICIDE PREVENTION TRAINING
PROGRAMS AND PROVIDE FUNDING TO
MAKE THE IDENTIFIED TRAINING
PROGRAM AVAILABLE TO ALL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. SERVING STUDENTS IN
GRADES SEVEN TO TWELVE AT NO
COST TO THE SCHOOLS.
THIS LEGISLATION IS SUBJECT TO A
BUDGET APPROPRIATION AND IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT SCHOOLS
ARE NOT REQUIRED TO USE
A TRAINING PROGRAM.
WHICH WILL BE OFFERED ON A
VOLUNTARY BASIS.
THE GOAL OF AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
NINE IS TO BETTER EQUIP IN
SUPPORT SCHOOLS BY PROVIDING
ACCESS TO TRAINING AND A COST
EFFECTIVE AND CONVENIENT MANNER.
TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF OUR
STUDENTS.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED NO
OPPOSITION AND THE SUPPORT FROM
VARIOUS ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING SUICIDE PREVENTION
ADVOCATES LGBTQ YOUTH ADVOCATES
MENTAL HEALTH ADVOCATES PARENTS
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND
PARTNERSHIP.
ON AN ISSUE THAT IS HITS CLOSE
TO HOME.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU YOUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RICK SOBRE
AND I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA. THE
NATION'S LARGEST STATEWIDE LGBT
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATION.
A QUALITY CALIFORNIA BRINGS THE
VOICES OF LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL
TRANSGENDER AND QUEER PEOPLE AND
ALLIES. TO INSTITUTIONS OF POWER
IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES
STRIVING TO CREATE A WORLD THAT
IS HEALTHY JUST AND FULLY EQUAL
FOR ALL. PEOPLE.
WE ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THIS
BILL ALONG WITH THE TREVOR
PROJECT AND WE THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL TO BUILD ON AB
TWENTY TO FORTY SIX.
WHICH EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND
THE TREVOR PROJECT ALSO PROBABLY
COSPONSORED IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN.
I LIKE TO KEEP MY TESTIMONY
BRIEF CONCEDE ANY TIME REMAINING
TO MY COLLEAGUE AT THE TREVOR
PROJECT.
BUT I LIKE TO SAY THAT LGBTQ YOU
ARE UP TO FOUR TIMES MORE LIKELY
TO ATTEMPT SUICIDE THAN THEIR
NON LGBTQ PEERS.
THANKFULLY REACHES RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN THAT HAVING AT LEAST ONE
SUPPORTIVE ADULTS IN THEIR LIVES
CAN SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THAT
RISK.
FOR OUR LGBTQ YOUTH.
RESEARCH HAS ALSO SHOWN THAT THE
NUMBER ONE PERSON A FELLOW
STUDENT TURNS TO WHEN TRYING TO
HELP A FRIEND WHO MIGHT BE
EXPERIENCING SUICIDAL THOUGHTS.
IS A TEACHER.
THIS BILL WILL EMPOWER OUR
TEACHERS
AND PROVIDE THEM WITH THE TOOLS
THEY NEED TO BE THE SUPPORT OF
ADULTS THAT THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
NEED.
WE URGE THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT
FOR THIS CRITICAL LEGISLATION TO
HELP SAVE YOUNG LIVES THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SEARCH SHARON
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SAM BRINTON
AND I SERVICE THE HEAD OF
ADVOCACY IN GOVERNMENT FAIRS FOR
THE TREVOR PROJECT. WE ARE THE
NATION'S LARGEST SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND CRISIS
INTERVENTION PROGRAM FOR LGBT
YOUTH.
OUR TWENTY FOUR SEVEN HOTLINE
AND DIGITAL SERVICES ARE TRACKED
DIRECTLY SERVE SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND CALLERS THIS YEAR ALONG
WITH CHARTERS AND TEXTURES WHO
HAVE NOWHERE ELSE TO TURN.
OUR EDUCATION WORK INCLUDES
ADVOCATING FOR IMPROVED SCHOOL
POLICIES SUCH AS THE MODEL
SCHOOLS APPROACH USED IN A
SUCCESSFUL AB TWENTY FORTY SIX
AS WELL AS PARTICULAR TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT TEACHERS AND
GUIDANCE COUNSELORS CAN ACCESS
ONLINE. WIFE THIS TRAINING SO
CRITICAL WE RECOGNIZE THAT LONG
BEFORE CRISIS A PERSON CAN
BENEFIT FROM EVEN ONE PERSON THE
LIFE WAS BEEN TRAINED IN
CULTURALLY COMPETENT
RECOGNITION.
OF WARNING SIGNS OF SUICIDE TO
MITIGATE THE CRISIS OF YOUTH
SUICIDE IN CALIFORNIA WE MUST
RECOGNIZE THAT EDUCATION IS
PREVENTION. I WANT TO CLOSE MY
REMARKS FOR THE FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE OF ONE OF OUR AMAZING
VOLUNTEERS WHO RECEIVE TRAINING
WE HOPE LEGISLATION LIKE AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY NINE WOULD
PROVIDE TO CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
AND STAFF. THEY SAID.
SUICIDE PREVENTION TRAINING OF
LIKE RECEIVING THE RESULT OF
STONE FOR COMMUNICATING WITH
INDIVIDUALS DEALING WITH A
MEASURABLE IMMEASURABLE PAIN
TRAUMA AND HOPELESSNESS.
IT EMPOWERS US WITH ESSENTIAL
SKILLS TO BREAK THROUGH THE
OFTEN IMPENETRABLE WALLS THAT
ARISE AND STRENGTHENED OVER A
LIFETIME FOR INDIVIDUALS DEALING
WITH TRAUMA MENTAL ILLNESS AND
THOUGHTS OF SUICIDAL IDEATION.
THROUGH TRAINING I FOUND MYSELF
IMPARTED WITH AN ABUNDANCE OF
RESOURCES TO UTILIZE NOT ONLY
WHEN SPEAKING WITH YOUTH THAT
MAY BE SUICIDAL. BUT ALSO WITH
THE TOOLS THAT THAT EXTENDED
BEYOND THE LINES OF THE TURNER
PROJECT AND INTO MY PROFESSIONAL
CAREER.
WE OUGHT TO TRY TO PROJECT ARE
ASKING YOU TO GIVE THE TOOLS TO
BREAK THROUGH A STUDENTS PAIN
AND PROVIDE A TEACHER OR SCHOOL
STAFF MEMBER THE WORDS AND
RESOURCES TO SAVE A LIFE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY NINE.
THANK YOU SAM WELL DONE I'VE ANY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
KATHLEEN HALL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PARENT TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
BRENNAN MARCHING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
GORDON DOWNEY WITH AMERICAN
FOUNDATION FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND ALSO AS AN
INDIVIDUAL MEMBER OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH POLICY WORK GROUP IN
SUPPORT.
ACCU ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION.
A SANE KNOW OPPOSITION OVER IT
BEHIND THE RELATIVE AND THANK
YOU.
FOR PARTNERING ON THIS MISTER
BERMAN AND AND CALL A CALIFORNIA
AND OTHERS THE TREVOR PROJECT
YOU DO GREAT WORK IN THIS AREA.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THOSE
STUDENTS WHO ARE TOUGH
CHALLENGES WHATEVER THEY MAY BE
AND I'VE SEEN IN MY OWN
CLASSROOM.
WHEN YOU SEE A STUDENT WHO JUST
ISN'T ENOUGH SO IS WRONG AND YOU
SAY WELL WHAT'S GOING ON IN YOUR
LIKE WHAT'S HAPPENING OUT THERE
AND I'LL SAY WELL.
I TOLD MY MOM HAS GAINED NOW I
GET KICKED OUT HOUSE AND THEY
FIND THEMSELVES VERY VULNERABLE
IN THE WORLD. AND THEY MAY MAKE
CHOICES WE DON'T WANT THEM TO
MAKE SO IT'S PROJECTS LIKE
YEAR'S EFFORTS LIKE YOURS THAT
HELP SOLVE IN.
HOW HELP OFFER SOME SOLUTIONS TO
THE CHALLENGES ARE YOU THAN
OTHERS?
OF FIND THEMSELVES IN TODAY
EDUCATION IS PREVENTION AYE LIKE
THAT.
ANY OTHERS IN BEHIND THEM
MISTER. ANY OTHERS.
BUT THE MOVE BY MR THURMAN.
SECOND I MISTER.
KILEY.
AND.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THE. WHAT YOU SAID IS THE
PERFECT CLOSE?
SIDES RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. O'DONNELL AYE BUT DONAL
AYE KILEY KILEY AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA I. MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
THURMAN. THURMOND AYE WEBER.
WEBER AYE SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO
THE BILL'S OUT THANK YOU.
WELL DONE.
OUT WITH THAT WILL GO TO MISTER
THURMAN.
WHO IS PRESENTING FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE NOT ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN? AB TWO ONE FIVE
THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO BE
BEFORE YOU TO PRESENT. AB TWO
ONE FIVE THREE.
THE BILL THAT WOULD PROVIDE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO OUR
TEACHERS TO SUPPORT LGBTQ
STUDENTS.
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY A DURING
THE INTERIM. TO HOST A
ROUNDTABLE DISCUSSION ON HOW WE
SUPPORT LGBTQ STUDENTS WHO OFTEN
ARE IMPACTED BY BULLYING. AND
HARASSMENT CAN MISTREATMENT.
AND.
AS PART OUR CONVERSATION WE
LANDED ON. THE NEED FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR OUR
EDUCATORS.
AS YOU KNOW OUR STUDENTS OFTEN
FACE VERBAL PHYSICAL IN ONLINE
HARASSMENT BOTH INSIDE AND OUT
OF SCHOOL.
IT'S MATTER FACT MORE THAN
NINETY PERCENT OF LGBTQ STUDENTS
REPORT HEARING ANTI LGBT Q.
REMARKS AMONG OTHER
DISCRIMINATORY ACTIONS BY THEIR
PEERS.
AS RESULT.
LGBTQ STUDENTS CANNOT BE THE
BEST STUDENTS THAT THEY CAN BE
WHEN THEY ARE SUBJECTED.
TO THESE CONDITIONS IT'S
DIFFICULT TO LEARN. WHEN YOU
FEAR FOR YOUR SAFETY OR YOU FEAR
DISCRIMINATION OR RETALIATION ON
A DAY TO DAY BASIS.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY LGBTQ
STUDENTS WHO HAVE EXPERIENCE
HARASSMENT OR ASSAULT. DO NOT
REPORT THESE INCIDENTS TO STAFF.
AB STUDENTS ARE NOT ALWAYS
CERTAIN AT BET THOSE WHO ARE
AROUND THEM WILL HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE KNOWLEDGE ON HOW TO
RESPOND APPROPRIATELY. THAT'S
WHY IT'S CRITICAL THAT TEACHERS
AND STAFF BE EQUIPPED WITH THE
TRAINING AND TOOLS
THEY NEED TO SUPPORT OUR LGBTQ
YOU.
TO ADDRESS THIS NEED THIS BILL
WILL REQUIRE THAT TEACHERS IN
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL RECEIVED
TRAINING ABOUT LGBTQ SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS
SO THEY CAN KNOW HOW TO BEST
SUPPORT. AND LGBTQ YOUTH.
WHEN THEY COME SEEKING SUPPORT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS RICK
SOBRE. EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND KATHY
SURE LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE IT
ACLU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
RICK SOBRE WITH THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE PRINT WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THURMAN.
AND WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR
THIS BILL.
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF
THE TRAINING THEY NEED TO CREATE
SAFE AND SUPPORTIVE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS INCLUDES LOOTING THOSE
WHO ARE LGBT Q.. AND MAYBE
FACING HARASSMENT OR LACK OF
ACCEPTANCE AT SCHOOL REJECTION
AT HOME OR DISCRIMINATION IN THE
BROADER COMMUNITY.
OUR TEACHERS AND STAFF ARE ON
THE FRONT LINES OF ENSURING THAT
ALL CHILDREN REGARDLESS OF
BACKGROUND ZIP CODE SEXUAL
ORIENTATION OR GENDER IDENTITY.
HAVE A SHOT AT THE AMERICAN
DREAM.
THAT OFTEN MEANS.
PROVIDING A SAFETY NET AGAINST
THE EFFECTS OF DISCRIMINATION
AND LACK OF ACCEPTANCE THAT
MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
AND ESPECIALLY OUR YOUTH FACE.
AND WHICH IS TOO OFTEN THE
RESULT OF HIGH WHICH ARE TOO
OFTEN RESULTS IN HIGHER DROPOUT
RATE.
LOWER ECONOMIC SUCCESS.
HIGH RATES OF HOMELESSNESS FOR
OUT OF TEN.
HOMELESS YOUTH IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE LGBTQ.
A HIGH RATES OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AND SUICIDE AMONG OTHER
DISPARITIES IN HEALTH AND WELL
BEING.
FUNDAMENTALLY EVERY CHILD IN
CALIFORNIA DESERVES A SAFE AND
SUPPORTIVE SCHOOL WHERE THEY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN
AND SUCCEED.
WHEN LGBT Q. STUDENTS HAVE THAT
SUPPORT IN SCHOOL THEIR
LIKELIHOOD OF OVERCOMING THESE
DISPARITIES THE DISPARITIES I
MENTIONED.
AND SUCCEEDING IN LIFE INCREASES
SIGNIFICANTLY.
THAT'S WHY A QUALITY CALIFORNIA
IS SO DEDICATED TO IMPROVING
SCHOOL ENVIRONMENTS AND MAKING
THEM SAFER AND MORE INCLUSIVE.
IT'S WHY WE'VE LOST LAUNCH ARE
SAFE AND SUPPORTIVE SCHOOLS
PROGRAM TO ASSESS WHAT SCHOOLS
ARE DOING TO PROTECT AND SUPPORT
THEIR LGBTQ STUDENTS AND
HIGHLIGHT BEST PRACTICES FROM
SCHOOLS. THAT ARE CREATING
INNOVATIVE INITIATIVES AND
ACHIEVING POSITIVE OUTCOMES.
ULTIMATELY WE KNOW THAT
SUPPORTIVE TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
STAFF CAN CHANGE OUR CHILDREN'S
LIVES THEY CAN GIVE AND LGBTQ
KID FROM LONG BEACH ARE OAKLAND
OR ORANGE COUNTY OR FRESNO OR
SAN DIEGO. A SHOT AT A BRIGHTER
FUTURE.
IF WE CAN EXPECT OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHERS AND STAFF TO
FILL THIS CRITICAL MISSION WE
HAVE TO GIVE THEM THE TOOLS THAT
THEY NEED TO SUPPORT. EVERY
CHILD WE THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMAN FOR CHAMPIONING THEIR
FOR CHAMPIONING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION AND WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
STAFF BY VOTING I. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHY SURE FOR
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA.
EXISTING LAWS INTENDED TO
PROVIDE PROTECTIONS FOR LGBTQ
STUDENTS AGAINST HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION AT SCHOOL. AMONG
OTHER PROTECTIONS LAW REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
ASSESS WHETHER ELEAZAR PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
HIGH SCHOOL TEACHERS ON SCHOOL
AND COMMUNITY RESOURCES FOR.
LGBTQ STUDENTS.
DESPITE THESE STEPS LGBTQ
STUDENTS STILL FACE BULLYING
HARASSMENT AND A LACK OF
ACCEPTANCE WHICH LEAD NOT ONLY
TO LOWER LEVELS OF ACADEMIC
EXCESS BUT ALSO TO A RANGE OF
OUT OF SCHOOL NEGATIVE OUTCOMES.
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE IS A
SIMPLE STEP TOWARDS ENSURING
THAT THE INFORMATION ON
RESOURCES REACHES THE PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT FOR STUDENTS.
BY REQUIRING TRAININGS FOR
TEACHERS OF UPS GRADES SEVEN
THROUGH TWELVE ON THE SCHOOL AND
COMMUNITY RESOURCES AVAILABLE
AND ON STRATEGIES TO SUPPORT
LGBTQ STUDENTS IN THEIR SCHOOLS.
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE WILL
HELP SCHOOLS AND TEACHERS CREATE
THE SUPPORT OF AN INCLUSIVE
SCHOOLS WE NEED WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON VERY IT'S NEVER
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT SUPPORTIVE
AMENDED WE WOULD TOTALLY SUPPORT
THE BILLS HAVE A LIST WITH THE
SIX WEEK TIMELINE LOOK THAT'S
COMPETITION THE AUTUMN HOPE THE
BILL MOVES FOR IMPORT OR. TAKE.
SENATE BRITAIN HAD OF ADVOCACY
IN GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR THE
TREVOR PROJECT WE STAND SUPPORT.
DANIELLE CANADA KAISER ON BEHALF
OF COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
AURORA SUMMERS FROM THE SOURCE
OF THE B. TEACH YOU CENTER AND I
SAW A CALIFORNIA AND FULL
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING OPPOSITION ANY CONCERT WE
HAVE THE RAIL NO SING NINE THAT
THIS RECORDING YOU WROTE OF MOVE
I'M A DOCTOR WEBER. SECOND BY.
MR MCCARTY.
THE MOTION IS.
.
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING.
LACKEY.
KALRA.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE THURMOND AYE
THURMOND AYE. WEBER.
WEBER I.
THE BILL WAS FOR VOTED IS OUT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE WITH THAT WILL
DOCTOR WEBER WILL BE PRESENTING
A FINAL SIXTEEN EIGHTY TWO SIX
ZERO ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ON YOU TO PRESENT TO YOU
AB TWENTY SIX A ONE WHICH
EXTENDS A CALIFORNIA HEALTHY USE
ACT.
COMPREHENSIVE SEX EDUCATION AND
HIV PREVENTION MANDATES ON
TRADITIONAL. AUNTS TREES THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS TO CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
AT THE TIME WHEN WE PRESENTED
A. B. OF TWENTIES AT THE FIRST
BILL IN TERMS OF THE HEALTHY
YOUTH ACT. IT WAS NOT MY EVER MY
THOUGHT THAT IT WOULD NOT APPLY
TO ALL SCHOOLS BECAUSE OF SEX
EDUCATION HEALTHY EDUCATION. IS
SOMETHING THAT EVERY CHILD
SHOULD HAVE A SYSTEM MEETS THIS
FUNDAMENTAL AS READING WRITING
AND MATH AND THE SCIENCES ARE
AND WHERE WE.
AND BUT OTHERS HAD A TENDENCY
TO NOT SEE IT BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
CALL IT OUT EVEN THOUGH HE SAID
IT WAS FOR PUBLIC SCHOOLS WE
DIDN'T CALL IT OUT. AND SO
THEREFORE AB TWENTY SIX A ONE
EXIST TODAY TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL
STUDENTS RECEIVE COMPREHENSIVE
SEXUAL HEALTH EDUCATION AND HIV
PREVENTION EDUCATION. AT LEAST
ONCE IN MIDDLE SCHOOL AND IN
HIGH SCHOOL WITH INSTRUCTION
THAT IS ACCESSIBLE FOR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES AND ENGLISH
LEARNERS. THIS BILL REALLY SETS
A FUND MUCH A FOUNDATIONAL
BASELINE FOR SEX EDUCATION IN
CHARTER SCHOOLS WHILE
MAINTAINING SIGNIFICANT
FLEXIBILITY FOR CHARTERS TO
DECIDE WHAT CURRICULUM THEY
ADOPTED WHAT SPECIFIC GRAYSON
PROVIDE INSTRUCTION AND OTHER
CURRICULA ELEMENTS.
THE RESEARCH IS CLEARLY YOUNG
PEOPLE CRITICALLY NEED HELP
QUALITY HEALTH EDUCATION.
SEXUAL HEALTH EDUCATION MORE
THAN HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS ARE SEXUALLY ACTIVE IN
THE TWELFTH GRADE CALIFORNIA'S
GOING STI RATES ARE HIGHEST IN
YOUNG PEOPLE AGES FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR. AND SADLY NEARLY
TWELVE TO TEN PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
EXPERIENCE SEXUAL DATING
VIOLENCE AND PHYSICAL DATING
VIOLENCE WISP OF RESPECTIVELY.
AS CALIFORNIA SEEKS TO ADDRESS
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND ABUSE
COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL HEALTH
EDUCATION WITH ITS FOCUS ON
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS CONSENT
AND CHALLENGING NEGATIVE JIM
JUST GENDER STEREOTYPES IS
ESSENTIAL. FOR PREVENTING THESE
NEGATIVE BEHAVIORS BEFORE THEY
START. AT A TIME WHEN FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR ABBOTT FOR
ADOLESCENT SEXUAL REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH IS BEING CUT CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO DO MORE TO ENSURE THAT
CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENTS HAVE THE
SAME ACCESS.
THE COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL HEALTH
EDUCATION THAT'S ALL OF THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS AB TWENTY
SIX ONE DOES THIS BY ENSURING
THAT ALL CHARTER SCHOOLS PROVIDE
INSTRUCTION ON COMPREHENSIVE
SEXUAL HEALTH EDUCATION.
WITH ME TODAY OF THIS BILL
SPONSORED BY ACLU THE BLACK
WOMAN OF WELLNESS AND AT ACTS
FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS. OF WITH ME
TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX A ONE IS NANCY
BURGERS FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
ON THE SAN FRANCISCO. ROY SUMMER
IS A SENIOR AT THE SALIA
UNIVERSITY PREPARATORY HIGH
SCHOOL AND PHILLIP FULLEST OUT
BURLINGAME WILL BE HERE FROM
ACLU FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
TWO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES UNLESS
YOU LIKE SPLIT THE TIME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DOCTOR
NANCY BURKE CLASS AN ADOLESCENT
HEALTH RESEARCHER AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO.
FOR MORE THAN FIFTEEN YEARS I'VE
EVALUATED SEX EDUCATION PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
IN THAT TIME OUR STATE HAS MADE
GREAT STRIDES IN IMPROVING THE
HEALTH OF ADOLESCENTS
THIS IS ATTRIBUTABLE IN PART TO
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL HEALTH
INFORMATION AND SERVICES FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE.
RESEARCH HAS MADE CLEAR THAT SEX
EDUCATION THAT ADDRESSES BOTH
ABSTINENCE AND BIRTH CONTROL CAN
HAVE A POSITIVE EFFECT ON
ADOLESCENTS DELAYING SEXUAL
ACTIVITY. INCREASING CONDIMENT
CONTRACEPTIVE USE AND REDUCING
RATES OF UNINTENDED PREGNANCY.
NEW RESEARCH SHOWS ADDITIONAL
IMPACT WHEN EDUCATORS TALK WITH
STUDENTS ABOUT GENDER
STEREOTYPES SEXUAL ORIENTATION
SEXUAL HARASSMENT CONSENT AND
HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS.
ADOLESCENTS TURNED TO MANY
SOURCES TO LEARN ABOUT SEX AND
RELATIONSHIPS THEIR PARENTS
FRIENDS SIBLINGS MOVIES AND TV
THE INTERNET. AND OFTEN THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY FIND IS
CONFUSING MISLEADING OR JUST
WRONG.
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY IS ACT
INSURERS THAT STUDENTS HAVE THE
KNOWLEDGE AND THE SKILLS TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR BODIES FORMER
SPEC POLL IN CONSENSUAL
RELATIONSHIPS AND PROTECT THEIR
SEXUAL HEALTH.
A FEW YEARS AGO I WORKED ON THE
EVALUATION OF A NEW SEX
EDUCATION PROGRAM FOR NINTH
GRADE STUDENTS AT TEN CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN LOS ANGELES.
IT COVERED THE COMPREHENSIVE
RANGE OF TOPICS TOPICS NOW
REQUIRED BY THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY YOUTH ACT.
ONE YEAR LATER WE FOUND
CONTINUED POSITIVE EFFECTS ON
THEIR KNOWLEDGE ABILITY TO
MANAGE RISKY SITUATIONS
COMMUNICATION WITH THEIR
PARTNERS AND USE OF HEALTH
SERVICES.
UNFORTUNATELY THE CLASSES ENDED
WHEN THE FUNDING AND.
STUDENTS IN CHARTER SCHOOLS ME
THE SAME INFORMATION AS THEIR
PEERS IN TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. A RECENT STUDY IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY HAS SHOWN THAT THE
SEX EDUCATION RECEIVED BY
CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENTS IS OFTEN
LACKING.
RESEARCHERS FOUND THAT FEWER
THAN HALF OF THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
ADDRESSED KEY TOPICS LIKE CONDOM
USE SEXUAL ORIENTATION
COMMUNICATION WITH PARTNERS AND
PARENTS AND SEXUAL ASSAULT. THIS
IS NOT SUFFICIENT EDUCATION TO
PREPARE YOUNG PEOPLE FOR A
HEALTHY FUTURE.
NOR IS IT EQUITABLE ALL YOUNG
PEOPLE NEED AND DESERVE A ACCESS
TO ACCURATE COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL
HEALTH INFORMATION. AB TWENTY
SIX NO ONE RECOGNIZES THE NEEDS
OF THE GROWING NUMBER OF
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND ENSURES THAT THEY
HAVE A STRONG AND EVIDENCE BASED
FOUNDATION IN HOUSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
A GOVERNING MY NAME IS LARRY
SUMMERS I'M A SENIOR AT
UNIVERSITY PREPARATORY HIGH
SCHOOL WHICH IS AT HER SCHOOL
AND TULARE. COUNTY.
A I AM HERE IS EITHER PRESENT
AND IF FOR ACT REMAINING GIRLS
AND THE SOURCE OF THE BEACH HE
CENTER IN BY CELAYA AND I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI TWENTY
SIX OH ONE.
DURING MY TIME AS A STANDARD
CHARTER SCHOOL I DID NOT RECEIVE
FULLY COMPREHENDS OF SELF SET
SEXUAL HEALTH EDUCATION. LIKE MY
PEERS AT A PRICE I UNIFIED OPTED
TO GO TO A CHARTER SCHOOL TO
TAKE PART AND THEIR RIGOROUS
CURRICULUM BY DID NOT DECIDE OFF
INTENT INTENTIONALLY OPT OUT OF
SEX ED.
SEX ED ONLY TEACHES.
TAX AND NOT ONLY TEACH US ABOUT
HOW TO PROTECT OURSELVES OF SAFE
SEX BUT THANKS TO THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY YOUTH ACT STUDENTS ARE
TAUGHT. ABOUT THE SEXUALITY
SPECTRUM IN GENERATED GENDER
IDENTITY THE INCLUSION OF LGBTQ
EDUCATION NOT ONLY LAYS
FOUNDATION FOR.
LEAVE FOUNDATION FOR A KNOWLEDGE
CURRENT THAT.
MAYES FOUNDATION FOR KNOWLEDGE
GROUP. THAT HOLDS CANS LOW
BALLING FROM MY EXPERIENCE WHEN
YOUNG PEOPLE COME BROKE HIS OF
KNOWLEDGE INSTEAD OF FEARING THE
UNKNOWN WE EXPERIENCED LAST
BLAME CREE FRIENDSHIPS INSTEAD.
WE KNOW SOME OF THE INFORMATION
OF THAT CALIFORNIA HEALTHY YOUTH
ACTING PREGNANCY RATES HAVE
DROPPED THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
BUT NOT MANDATING SEX AND ENTER
SCHOOLS WE'RE LEAVING ABSTINENCE
ONLY EDUCATION ON THE TABLE FOR
HER SCHOOLS AND THE MEN ON THEIR
OWN DISCUSSION.
THESE ABSENCE ONLY EDUCATION
DOES NOT ONLY. DOES MORE HARM
THAN NO EDUCATION AT ALL.
THE ME TACTIC FOR USE OF ABSENCE
ON EDUCATION IS SHAMING THOSE
WHO CHOOSE NOT TO BE ABSENT OR
DON'T APPLY WITH THE MALE FEMALE
BINARY SPECTRUM.
THIS SHAMING NOT.
JUST IS ANOTHER FORM OF BOWLING
BY STUDENTS AND THE TEACHER
ANOTHER THIS SHAMING NEGATIVELY
FACT STUDENTS WHO ARE SURVIVORS
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT INDEED
VIOLENCE OR FINDING THEIR OWN
IDENTITY.
BY WITHHOLDING SEX AT A LARGE
PORTION OF THE NEXT GENERATION
WILL NOT LEARN HOW TO PROTECT
HOW PREPARE OURSELVES.
PROTECTION OF OUR HEALTH NORMAL
WE LEARN ABOUT HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS HEALTHY BOUNDARIES
OR LEARN ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE
DIFFERENT BUT STILL VERY NORMAL.
THERE'S NO REASON FOR HER SCHOOL
STUDENTS TO FALL BEHIND PUBLIC
SCHOOL STUDENTS.
WE OUGHT TO EXPECT EQUAL
EDUCATION REGARDLESS OF THE
INSTITUTION THANK YOU THANK YOU
WELL DONE. OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
KILEY JACKSON WOULD SAY NEW
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
GREAT THANK YOU JUST BRIEFLY
FILLER BURLINGAME WITH A SO YOU
OF CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
BRENT IN MARCH YOU WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
DANIEL KENDO KAISER ON BEHALF OF
COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
ANDREAS AND MIGUEL ON BEHALF OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
JOE MICHAEL FOR EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
IT IT ONE REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT.
RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT.
HI LIANE TRODDEN ON BEHALF OF
BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS A POW
CHO SPONSOR THIS BILL THINKING.
SARAH HUTCHINSON ON BEHALF OF I
FOR ONE AYE GIRLS SCHOOL
SPONSORING THIS BILL IN SUPPORT.
ISABEL GARCIA CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
RECOMMENDING A SUPPORTED OUR
APRIL MEETING.
WE TAKE YOU ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. OF ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AMY
BLOOMBERG ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION WE DO NOT HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION PANEL WE DO
SUPPORT THE POLICY IN GENERAL WE
DO HAVE SOME FISCAL AN EQUITY
CONCERNS. TO LOOK FOR TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR.
ON THESE ISSUES GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER OPPOSITION ARE.
YOU NEUTRALITY.
DO WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM
BEHIND THE THE RAIL SING NINE OF
TO EMOTIONAL THIS RECORD THE
MOVE BY MR MCCARTY SECOND AYE MR
THURMAN.
THE MOTION IS.
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL O'DONNELL
AYE AYE O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO. LACKEY.
KALRA.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE THURMAN.
THURMOND AYE WEBER AYE WEBER
AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU.
JERRY WAS
.
PARA IT'S.
SHERIFF IN TOWN.
EXACTLY.
IT'S RICE.
ALL RIGHT TO MISTER O'DONNELL
PLEASE PROCEED MINDFUL OF THE
VERY STRINGENT TWO WITNESSES TO
MINUTES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE
ESTABLISHING ESTABLISHES ONGOING
FUNDING FOR CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS. INNER K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS AT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR.
THIS BILL PROVIDES TWELVE
BILLION PER YEAR FOR REGIONAL
TECHNICAL SUPPORT THROUGH COUNTY
OFFICES
OF EDUCATION AS WELL THAT'S THE
LOCAL THE MORE LOCAL INDIVIDUALS
WHO HELPED CONNECT CT PROGRAMS.
WITH INDUSTRY THERE THE INDUSTRY
EXPERTS.
CT IS CRITICAL FOR STUDENTS AND
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY I
THINK YOU'RE HEARING THAT MORE
AND MORE YOUR DISTRICTS.
AS BUSINESSES NEED INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE TRAINED IN ON THE
TECHNICAL SIDE YOU'RE JUST NOT
JUST FROM THE UNIVERSITY SIDE
THE BACCALAUREATE SIDE.
AS A TEACHER I KNOW FIRST HAND
THAT CD PROGRAMS ENGAGE STUDENTS
AND REDUCE DROPOUT RATES.
STUDENTS NEED MULTIPLE PASSED
EXCESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT.
CT ENSURES THAT STUDENTS ARE
pBETTER PREPARED FOR LIFE AFTER
GRADUATION WHETHER THAT INCLUDES
COLLEGE OR LEAD STRAIGHT TO A
CAREER.
CURRENCY T. FUNDING STREAMS
EXPIRE THIS YEAR.
WE NEED TO MAINTAIN A STRONG
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THIS
LEGISLATOR HAS SUPPORTED IN THE
PAST AND TO BUILD ON THAT
INVESTMENT BY PROVIDING STABLE.
ONGOING FUNDING
TO K. TWELVE SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS PROPOSAL KEEPS THE EXISTING
INCENTIVE GRANT APPROACH INTACT.
AS IT IS PROVEN SUCCESSFUL
ENSURING DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA RECEIVE FUNDING. AND
THAT THIS REMAINS A PROGRAM THAT
INCENTIVIZE IS THE CREATION AND
SUPPORT.
STRONG CT PROGRAMS IN A FAIR AND
EQUITABLE MANNER.
WE SEE NO NEED TO DISRUPT THE
SUCCESSFUL EXISTING PROGRAMS BY
CREATING A NEW LEVEL OF
BUREAUCRACY WITH LOCAL CONSORTIA
COORDINATED BY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM THAT MAY END UP.
LESS EQUITABLE.
I RESPECT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM BUT I
AM NOT CONVINCED THAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES KNOW WHAT K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS NEED. NOR SHOULD
IT PLAY A ROLE IN MANAGING THEM.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE KEEPS
K. TWELVE DOLLARS IN THE K.
TWELVE SYSTEM.
THIS IS CLEARLY A BY FOR THIS IS
CLEARLY A BIPARTISAN ISSUE I AM
PROUD TO BE JOINED BY TWENTY
FIVE COLLEAGUES.
AS JOINT AUTHORS AND CO AUTHORS
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE
INCLUDING MISTER CHAVEZ MISTER
CARD ESTHER MCCARTY. A MISTER
THURMAN AND MANY OTHERS AND
TODAY WITH ME HERE IS OUR.
BUSINESS BURKE I BELIEVE WISHES
TO SPEAK TO THE ITEM AS WELL.
SHE IS OUT OF YOUR CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON CT AND OF
COURSE ONE OF THE JOINT OFFERS
AUTHORS ON THIS BILL IN A STRONG
PROPONENT.
CT.
I THINK YOU FOR HAVING ME AS THE
CHAIR OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND
ALSO IS THE PROUD SPONSOR JOINT
AUTHOR OF AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
THREE AND ONE I THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL AND ALL OF THAT
TWENTY FIVE BIPARTISAN MEMBERS
FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP. ON THIS
ISSUE.
THREE YEARS AGO WHEN WE
ESTABLISH THE CT INCENTIVE GRANT
WITH NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING I WAS A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THAT PROGRAM
AND THOUGHT IT WAS CRITICAL AT
THAT TIME TO FILL THE FUNDING.
GAP FOR CT.
AFTER HOLDING SELECT COMMITTEES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO SEE THE TREMENDOUS
SUCCESS IN SUPPORT OF THE C. T.
INCENTIVE BROWN WE'VE HEARD FROM
COUNTLESS TEACHERS STUDENTS. AND
BUSINESSES AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERS ABOUT THE AMAZING WORK
THAT IS BEING DONE AND THE
RESULTS OF THE INCENTIVE GRANT
PROGRAM.
HISTORICALLY ABOUT SEVENTY
PERCENT OF THE POPULATION DOES
NOT HAVE A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE
DEGREE.
AND THAT IS WHY IT IS SO
IMPORTANT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE EDUCATION COMMUNITY TO
BE FOCUSED ON COLLEGE AND COOLEY
CAREER READINESS FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
OUR STUDENTS ARE NOW COMPETING
IN A LOCAL AND GLOBAL ECONOMY
AND WE SHOULD BE DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO HELP THEM
SUCCEED.
THE FUNDING FOR CT PROGRAMS NOT
ONLY HELP STUDENTS DREAM OF
POSSIBILITIES FOR THEIR FUTURE
BUT THEY ALSO CREATE LOCAL BONDS
BETWEEN BUSINESS LABOR AND
GOVERNMENT THAT LAST
GENERATION'S.
WE MUST ENSURE ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY GAIN THE
SKILLS NECESSARY TO OBTAIN A JOB
THAT PROVIDES ECONOMIC SECURITY
FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND WE MUST
SUPPORT A STRONG AND GROWING
MIDDLE CLASS.
I HEARD A GREAT QUOTE.
A COUPLE MONTHS AGO AND ONE OF
MY SELECT COMMITTEE HEARINGS AND
IT WAS. IF WE TEACH TODAY'S
STUDENTS AS WE TAUGHT YESTERDAY
WE ROB THEM OF TOMORROW.
LET'S BE INNOVATIVE LETS BUILD
OUR ECONOMY AND LET'S GIVE OUR
STUDENTS A TOMORROW I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
ON AB SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ALSO WITH
ME HERE TODAY IS VALLEY WHOSE
VIEWS SUCH FROM THE FRESNO I
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
THEN JERRY SMITH. FROM THE
GERMAN SMITH FROM THE ACT
CALIFORNIA STATE BUILDING
TREATS.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M VALERIE
BICU SICH THE ADMINISTRATOR
FOR KRYCEK GET AND REGIONAL
OCCUPATIONAL PROGRAMS AT THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS I AM A
LOCAL SEATED RECIPIENT AS THE
FISCAL AGENT FOR A SEVENTEEN
DISTRICT CONSORTIUM. BUT ALSO
SERVE AS ONE OF THE REGIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
OR OUR TAXES WERE CALLED. AND WE
ARE IN PLACE TO SUPPORT
DISTRICTS AS THEY GROW IMPROVE
AND MAINTAIN THEIR LOCAL CT
PROGRAMS.
IT WAS EXPECTED THAT ALL K.
TWELVE DISTRICTS WOULD
PARTICIPATE IN THIS FUNDING
THROUGH THEIR SUBMISSION OF A
PLAN TO ENSURE THEIR SAFETY
PROGRAMS WOULD WORK TOWARDS
ATTAINING THE ELEVEN ELEMENTS OF
A HIGH QUALITY PROGRAM. AND TO
COMMIT TO THEIR DISTRICT MATCHED
REQUEST AMOUNT
APPLICATIONS WERE NOT
COMPETITIVE WITH WINNERS AND
LOSERS AND THE OUR TAPS WORKED
WITH DISTRICTS TO SUBMIT
COMPLETE APPLICATIONS THAT
QUALIFY FOR FUNDING IF THEY WERE
UNSUCCESSFUL. THEIR FIRST
ATTEMPT
AS IN OUR TAP WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE PROMOTED
VARIETY OF INSTRUCTIONAL
STRATEGIES AVAILABLE TO
DISTRICTS THAT INCLUDES LINK
LEARNING PARTNERSHIP ACADEMIES
MAGNET SCHOOLS. AND OUR APPEASE
TO NAME A FEW OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS WE'VE DEVELOPED AND
EXPANDED RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
CT STAFF IN OUR REGIONS.
WHAT MAKES US EFFECTIVE IS THAT
ALL OF US HAVE AND CONTINUE TO
RUN CTN ROP PROGRAMS FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND WERE ACTUAL
PRACTITIONERS OF WALK THE TALK?
ACCORDING TO CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION CODE EACH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS CHARGED WITH
PREPARING THEIR STUDENTS FOR
BOTH COLLEGE AND CAREER. AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE WOULD
ENSURE THAT DISTRICTS HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO DO SO ARE ROLLING
QUE TWELVE IS TO HELP STUDENTS
EXPLORE THEIR INTERESTS AND
TALENTS WERE PROVIDING THE
INFORMATION. ABOUT HOW THEY
RELATE TO THE WIDE VARIETY OF
CAREER PATHS AND WITHIN INDUSTRY
SECTORS AND WHERE THEY CAN GO TO
PURSUE THEM FOLLOWING HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION. K. TWELVE CT
PROGRAMS INCLUDE THE
PARTICIPATION OF INDUSTRY
PARTNERS AND WE PLACE THOUSANDS
OF STUDENTS IN WORK SITES AS A
COMPONENT OF MANY OF OUR PEOPLE
CLASSES.
IF THE FUNDS BECOME ADMINISTERED
THROUGH SOME COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROCESS ACROSS THE REGION AND
BECOME LIMITED TO A SMALL NUMBER
OF INDUSTRY SECTORS A LOT OF THE
WORK WITH OUR CURRENT INDUSTRY
PARTNERS WILL BE LOST AS THERE
IS NO GUARANTEE THAT HIGH SCHOOL
PROGRAMS. WOULD CONTINUE TO BE
FUNDED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. IN
CLOSING IF YOU DESIRE TO
MAINTAIN OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS AND PROVIDE A
COMPREHENSIVE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM WHILE PREPARING ALL
STUDENTS FOR COLLEGE AND CAREER
READY.
AND HAVING AN IMPACT ON
EMPLOYMENT AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND MAKING USE OF
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE.
THEN I ENCOURAGE YOU TO PASS AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE IS THE WAY
TO SUPPORT CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION IN THE K. TWELVE
SYSTEM ON A PERMANENT BASIS
THANK.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JEREMY
SMITH HERE BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION WE AGREE WITH WHAT
MR O'DONNELL SAID.
A.
.
AND MAKING SURE THAT THIS
PROGRAM STAYS AT THE DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF IT A REMAINING IN
THEIR.
WE ARE AND.
ON THE RECORD IT'S IN AND
SUPPORTING THAT END DIFFERENT
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEES AS WELL
IT'S BECAUSE THE CD E. HANDLES
THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM IS PRETTY
SIMPLE.
THEY ARE OF BEST POSITION TO
FIGURE OUT WHY THERE AREN'T MORE
KIDS GETTING EXPOSURE TO THESE
CLASSES BECAUSE THESE KIDS.
DON'T REALIZE THAT THERE'S A
WORLD OF WORK OUT THERE FOR THEM
THAT DOESN'T INVOLVE. A
TRADITIONAL FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY
EDUCATION NOW TO BE CLEAR WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF.
FURTHERING ONE'S EDUCATION
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL WE CALL IT A
PARTNERSHIP AFTER THREE TO FIVE
YEARS OF OUR FRIENDSHIP PROGRAM
BASICALLY COLLEGE FOR
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS.
THESE KIDS HAVE BEEN EARNING AND
LEARNING.
WHILE.
HONING THE SKILLS OF THE CRAFT
THAT WILL FOLLOW THEM FOR THEIR
ENTIRE LIVES.
THEY DO THIS.
IN THE JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM AT ALMOST NO
COST TO THEM.
THAT PARTICULAR SUBSET OF THE
ESTATE OF PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
SYSTEM IN THE STATE GRADUATES
NINETY TWO PERCENT OF THE
OPPRESSES THE COME THROUGH.
IS PAID FOR BY THE LABOR
MOVEMENT BY THE UNIONS THAT
PARTICIPATE IN IT. AND THESE.
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN A GUY SAID
ARE EARNING A LEARNING WHILE.
HONING THEIR SKILLS AND THEY.
ARE EARNING PENSION CREDITS AND
HEALTH CARE AND SICK TIME AND
ALL THE THINGS WE ALL TAKE FOR
GRANTED IN JOBS THAT ARE
CONSTRUCTION.
IN THE MEANTIME THERE'S TONS OF
WORK OUT THERE YOU GUYS ARE
MAKING ALL KINDS OF CHOICES HERE
WHETHER IT'S SB ONE OR THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FIX.
YOU'RE REQUIRING SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORK FORCES ON CERTAIN
TYPES OF PUBLIC OF CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS SO YOU ARE MAKING
DECISIONS HERE TO CREATE SO MUCH
WORK FOR CONSTRUCTION WORKERS.
THAT THAT THAT'S GONNA BE A
VIABLE CAREER FOR MANY HE'S A
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN A MOVIE FOR
SO IN CLOSING I'D LIKE TO SAY
TWO THINGS ONE.
IT'S IMPORTANT.
TO US THAT THE.
PLANNERS OF.
.
MISTER DONALSONVILLE.
BE.
IN ANY KIND OF ANSWER THAT
COMES OF THIS.
ISSUE THIS YEAR US STRONG.
TO STAINED FUNDING FOR HIGH
QUALITY CG PROGRAMS WITH
REGIONALLY BASED.
.
OF CD  STAFF TO HELP THESE
DISTRICTS NAVIGATE ON NOT ONLY
GETTING THE INCENTIVE GRANT BUT
PUTTING INTO PLACE FOR THOSE
REASONS WERE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALYSSA LYNCH
METROPOLITAN EDUCATION DISTRICT
REPRESENTING CAMPBELL UNION HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT EAST SIDE UNION
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT. LOS GATOS
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT MILPITAS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT SANTA
CLARA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
SAN JOSE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JERRY SHELTON ON BEHALF OF QUE
ROB THE ASSOCIATION OF CAREER IN
COLLEGE READINESS ORGANIZATIONS
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NANCY LOW COST REPRESENTING
SEVENTY ONE SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS
PART OF A CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION CONSORTIUM AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JULIE DUNCAN
SUPERINTENDENT TRI VALLEY ROP I
REPRESENT DUBLIN LIVERMORE
VALLEY AND PLUS DO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON BARRETT SNYDER
BFF UP PROJECT LEAD THE WAY AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
EDUCATION TECHNOLOGY
PROFESSIONALS AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE ANGELA REED
ON BEHALF OF SAN GAPS THE SAME
BURNING DINO DISTRICT ADVOCATES
FOR BETTER SCHOOLS ALL THE
GOVERNING BOARDS AND DISTRICTS
ATTENDANCE EXAMINING THE
BERNADINE ACCOUNTING. IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
KELLY MILLER NAPA COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION AND SEE TOOK
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDER IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS CHRIS MCCAIN
WE ON BEHALF OF THE COMPUTING
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS JEFF SCHMIDT THE CITY
CORNELIA ST OCCUR COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION ON THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR CT I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
SHARE AROUND HER BUTTE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
AND.
SEE TAP REGION ONE FULL SUPPORT.
SARAH ROGERS WITH CAST FUND
SUPPORT.
KIMBER NEGATIVE FROM DUNSMUIR
JOINT UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
JAMIE PHILLIPS CASBAH IN
SUPPORT.
A BRISK MAGNANI ON BEHALF OF RIO
TINTO BORATE U. S. BORAX AND
MITSUBISHI CEMENT CORPORATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS
WALKER WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SHEET METAL AIR
CONDITIONED CONTRACTORS IN
SUPPORT AND THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MARIE DELA CRUZ CHIEF BUSINESS
OFFICER OF METROPOLITAN
EDUCATION DISTRICT REPRESENTING
CAMEL UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
EAST SIDE UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT LOS GATOS SARATOGA HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT. MCPETERS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT SAN JOSE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
SANTA CLARA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
ERNIE SILVER FOR THE SCHOOL FOR
INTEGRATED ACADEMICS AND
TECHNOLOGIES AND SUPPORT.
SEAN LOOSE WITH THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS REPRESENTING OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ASSISTANCE AND ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION INSPIRED.
ERIC DEL SUPERINTENDENT OF SANTA
GHETTO UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER STAHL WHO WERE
ASSOCIATE SUPERINTENDENT BACK
WILL UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
FULL SUPPORT.
MOLLY SLINGING UNIVERSITY
PREPARE TORY SCHOOL AND FULL
SUPPORT.
ISTINA ARAGON AT ARCADY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT FULL SUPPORT.
FRED JONES CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION INSOFAR.
ALL RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
BOTH FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE.
THAT AFTERNOON DEREK CLINICS ON
BEHALF OF SAN
SCHOOL UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
MATT PATTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
ANDREA BALL ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND ALSO THE SAN JOSE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
JEFF MILLER DONOVAN BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA AUTO BODY ASSOCIATION
THE AUTOMOTIVE SERVICE COUNCILS
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
AUTOMOTIVE BUSINESS COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I KNOW HOW THE REST BUT ALSO ON
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TOM TOWARD
EXCELLENCE PART.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERRY G. ARENA
SUPERINTENDENT NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY ROP I REPRESENT ANAHEIM
UNION FULLERTON JOINT UNION
BRAILLE LINDA LOS ALAMEDA US AND
PLACENTA YORBA LINDA. UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND FULL
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHY CAN'T
ADMINISTRATIVE NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY ROP IN FULL SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CHARLIE RAY CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRIAL
MATERIALS ASSOCIATION SPORT.
VERY AND OIL DIRECTOR OF PROTECT
AT THE WILLIAM IS HURTING IN
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT IN FULL
SUPPORT NEEDS AS WELL YOU HAVE A
LETTER FROM THE SANTA CLARITA.
CAREER COLLABORATIVE CONSORTIA
WITCHES ALL OF OUR EMPLOYERS AND
US YOU HAVE THE SIGNATURES THERE
AS WELL THANK YOU.
CHERYL WRITER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR CAREER DEVELOPMENT WITH A
PLASTER COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION FULL SUPPORT.
JUST A MARKETS COORDINATOR CT
PLASTIC COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT CTE PARENT AND FULL
SUPPORT.
ALICIA PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF
TECHNO AND STRONG SUPPORT.
STEVE HENDERSON REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS.
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
TONY OF OUR.
DIRECTOR OF PARTICULAR
EDUCATION REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL
PROGRAM AS WELL AS BEING THE
REGION FIVE REGIONAL ASSISTANCE
A PROVIDER.
ITS FULL SUPPORT.
HI LINDA RECALL CLING COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION ALL THE
DISTRICTS WITHIN OUR.
COUNTY REGION OUR FULL SUPPORT.
JERRY WHEN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
EDUCATION OFFICE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDER IN FULL
SUPPORT.
VERY RIGHTED MERCED COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND FULL
SUPPORT.
IF YOU MORE SPRINTER COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION REPRESENTING
EIGHTEEN SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE
CONSORTIUM IN FULL SUPPORT.
PAM LOPEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION IN SUPPORT.
KATHY HALL REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA IN SUPPORT.
MAP BACK REPRESENTING THAT THE
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY ARE OP IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
SINCE IZZY HARSHLY WITH HUMBOLDT
COUNTY OFFICE BED AND A PARENT
I'M IN SUPPORT OF BILL.
STEVEN JACKSON'S NO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION SUPPORT.
CHRIS BROWN CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS ALSO
MEMBERS OF THE GET REAL
COALITION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
JENNIFER BROWN BE UP THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE HAVE A SUPPORTIVE AMENDED
POSITION WE SUPPORT THE ONGOING
FUNDING FOR CT  BUT WOULD
JUST LIKE TO SEE SOME AMENDMENTS
MADE SO THAT. UP PROGRAMS AND
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS LINKED
LEARNING CAN I UTILIZE THIS
FUNDING FOR THAT THE SUPPORT OF
ACTIVITIES THAT THE UTILIZED AS
WELL THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
ANYTHING THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WILL GO
FILED YOUR WITNESS.
RULES BUT I DO.
WANT TO SAY THAT I'M A PROUD TO
AND AUTHOR OF THIS BILL. I
WON'T.
.
STATE AGAIN THEIR COLLEGE CAREER
PATHWAY BENEFITS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID TO THEM
VERY CLEARLY.
I WILL SAY THAT WE HAVE HEARD
FROM NUMEROUS.
SUPERINTENDENTS FROM COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION WHO HAVE
SAID THAT.
NOT ONLY IS RENEWAL IMPORTANT
BUT MAKING SURE THAT. OF THESE
DOLLARS DON'T GET FURTHER
SEPARATED FROM THEIR ABILITY TO
DO THIS WORK AND THEY DON'T WANT
TO HAVE A GREATER DISTANCE IS
CRITICAL. AND.
IF NOTHING ELSE I'D SAY SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECAUSE WHEN ELSE HAS
IN THE BILL UNITED AS MANY
SECTORS AS WE JUST SAW. USUALLY
WHEN.
WELL THANK YOU CAN.
USUALLY IT WHEN THE LINE WRAPS
AROUND IN THIS CHAMBER IS
BECAUSE EVERYONE SAYING I'M
OPPOSED THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT
EVERYONE CAN SAY WE SUPPORT. AND
I GUESS ON A PERSONAL NOTE I'VE
NEVER HAD THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE SUPPORT ANY AMOUNT
BILLS.
SO YOU HAVE TO SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
IF I WON I WON ALSO.
AUTHORS FOR.
PUTTING TOGETHER THIS BILL BUT.
BUT.
YOU NO I I GUESS MYCONCERN LIES
NOT IN THE BILL ITSELF BUT IN IN
IN THE WHOLE LCF F. SITUATION.
BECAUSE THIS BILL DOES NOT
NECESSARILY PRODUCE ANY NEW
MONEY. IS SHIFTING AROUND OF THE
CURRENT MONEY.
THE PEOPLE NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THAT
THAT DATA NINETY EIGHT IS NINETY
EIGHT IS NINETY EIGHT PROBLEM IT
EIGHT AND SO. I THINK IN THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF LC A FAST WE
EX WE HAD EXPECTED PEOPLE TO
MAINTAIN. THE SAME EFFORTS IN
THE SAME PROGRAMS THEY HAD
BEFORE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY SCHOOLS DID
NOT DO THAT.
BECAUSE THEY TOOK THE CT MONEY
THAT WAS THERE PUT IT BACK INTO
THE BASE GRANT AND DIDN'T
NECESSARILY FEEL THE NEED TO
FUND. THE CT PROGRAMS.
AND SO I WANT TO SAY THAT
BECAUSE IF FOR SOME STRANGE
REASON.
THE GRANTING PROCESS OF WHATEVER
HAPPENS HERE DOESN'T WORK OUT
THE WAY IT SHOULD AT SOME POINT
WITH FOLKS AFTER A PERIOD OF
TIME. ASISTIR STILL SHOULD HAVE
A COMMITMENT TO CT.
BECAUSE THE MONEY IS STILL
THERE.
AND THE KIDS ARE STILL THERE AND
THE NEED IS STILL THERE.
AND SO I THINK WHEN WE DID THE
GRANT PROCESS SEVERAL YEARS AGO
BEFORE SOME OF YOU WERE HERE. WE
END UP DOING IT BECAUSE SCHOOLS
REMAINED ON DOING THE DISTRICTS
DID NOT DO CT. YET THE MONEY
THAT THE CATEGORICAL FUNDS THAT
HAD BEEN IN CT
WE'RE BASICALLY NOW PUT BACK
INTO EL CFF AND IT'S THE BASS
GRANT.
AND THE ASSUMPTION WAS THAT
THOSE THAT THEY WOULD CONTINUE
IT AND SOME SCHOOLS DID AND SOME
DID NOT.
AND SO AS A RESULT THEY WE
CREATED THIS NEED THAT FOLKS
NEEDED TO BASICALLY DO CT AND WE
CREATED THIS QUIET PROCESS TO
KIND OF HELP KICK OFF THE
SITUATION.
BUT I JUST WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW
THAT THE MONEY IS THERE IN
SHOULD BE THERE IN THE LOCAL AND
IN THE BASS GRANT. AND LCF F. TO
DO C. T. BECAUSE IT WAS THERE
BEFORE THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA AND ALL THAT MONIES PUT
PUT IN. SO OFTEN TIMES WHEN THE
GOVERNOR VETOED THESE BILLS.
HE'S VETOING BECAUSE HE KEEPS
SAYING OVER AND OVER I DON'T
WANT CATEGORICAL WHEELS DID
BEGIN TO COME BACK AGAIN.
BECAUSE THE ALL THAT CATEGORICAL
MONEY WOULD BACK INTO IT SO I
THINK WE HAVE TO MAINTAIN AS
DISTRICTS A COMMITMENT TO SEE T.
E.. BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE OUR
KIDS ARE ALL OF OUR KIDS
SOMEONE A COLLEGE SOMEONE DO IN
CT  BUT THAT'S WHAT A WELL
ROUNDED DISTRICT DOES. IN TERMS
OF DEVELOPING COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAMS FOR ALL KIDS AND SO I
THINK WE DO THIS BUT IF FOR SOME
STRANGE REASON. STUFF DISAPPEARS
A FOR SOME STRANGE REASON THE
GOVERNOR DOESN'T SIGN THIS. WE
AS A STATE AND U. S. DISTRICT
SHOULD STILL HAVE A COMMITMENT
CT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I VERY MUCH MISTER
O'DONNELL AND.
MS BURKE FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
AND THAT AND BUILDING MOMENTUM.
AROUND THIS ISSUE.
I DO THINK THAT.
DOCTOR WEBER'S COMMENTS ARE
WELL TAKEN AYE BUT I THINK THIS
IS VERY IMPORTANT EFFORT ON BOTH
SIDES THESE LAST COUPLE YEARS
TO.
BRING THIS ISSUE I AM CAREER
EDUCATION.
BACK AND PUT IT FRONT AND
CENTER AND I THINK THAT YOUR
WORK HAS BEEN REALLY IMPORTANT
YOU BELT.
IMPRESSIVE COALITION OBVIOUSLY.
YOU'VE ENGAGED INDUSTRY AND
THAT I GOTTA GIVE A LITTLE SHOUT
OUT THE PLASTIC COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION I'M REALLY GLAD IT'S
HERE I'VE GONE AND SEEN THE
GREAT WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING ON
THIS FRONT. I CAN'T.
AND A STABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING
IS REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT
NOW I CAN'T RESIST THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE MY
LITTLE CRUSADE TO I RETIRE THE
TERM CT  AND INSTEAD JUST
START SAYING CAREER EDUCATION.
WHICH I THINK MIGHT BE A LITTLE
MORE FITTING BUT I'VE NOT
WITHSTANDING THAT ACQUITTAL.
HI I'M RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE
ON THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IF I GET AS CLOSE AS. I WILL.
I'M OKAY WITH THE WORD
VOCATIONAL EDUCATION TOO OUT SO
WE CAN ALL HAVE OUR TERM BUT WE
YEAR RECOGNIZES J. THAT CT
WHATEVER WE CALL IT. IS
IMPORTANT THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IT ENSURES DOLLARS SET
ASIDE FOR THIS EFFORT
INCENTIVIZE DISTRICTS IT
SUPPORTS STUDENTS IN THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NOW MADAM
SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL.
AGAIN THE THEN MOTION IS DUE
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
BY O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
THURMOND.
THERE MIGHT AYE WEBER. WEBER
AYE.
I KNOW YOU GUYS ARE NOT.
JUST YOU KNOW WITHOUT VOTE.
S. DENOUNCE THE VOTE WE ARE
COMING
ZERO SIX ZERO ZERO BILLS OUT
THANK YOU
.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA STUDENTS ARE
HERE FROM MY
DISTRICT
WE HAVE SOME STUDENTS A MILLICAN
WHERE THEY WHERE WHERE RAMS OUT
THERE ALRIGHT GREAT I'VE RAMIN
HOME. ACTUALLY MY DAUGHTER GOES
TO MILLIKEN AND WE HAVE SOME
RULINGS HERE WHERE THE WILSON
STUDENTS ALRIGHT I HAVE MANY IN
NEIGHBOR.
WHO EITHER TEACH THERE OR GO
THERE TODAY SO WELCOME BRUINS
AND RAMPS
TO THE STATE CAPITOL?
I'M GONNA FINISH UP HERE RECALL
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
.
I'M.
CONSENT CALENDAR FIRST.
WILL MOVED ITEM WILL.
CONSENT CALORIES AS FOLLOWS
ITEM NUMBER FOUR IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTY TWO BY MISTER WOOD THE
MOTION IS PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. ITEM NUMBER SIX
EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND NINE BY A MR
MAIENSCHEIN THE MOTION IS PASSED
TO THE JUDICIARY. ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWO ZERO THREE ONE BY
O'DONNELL THE MOTION IS PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY EIGHT BY MISTER WOOD
THE MOTION IS PASSED AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
FIVE. BY O'DONNELL THE MOTION IS
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS AB OR
THE I'M FOURTEEN. AB TWENTY
THREE ZERO ONE BY MISS BURKE AND
MOTIONS PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
IN ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
THREE ZERO FOUR THREE BY MISTER
BERMAN THE MOTION IS PASSED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSECUTIVE.
O'DONNELL I THINK O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY. KILEY AYE LACKEY. LACKEY
AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WEBER AYE WEBER AYE
SIX ZERO. SIX ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS PASSED AND WE HAVE.
SEVERAL BILLS.
THAT WE NEED TO GO BACK THROUGH
BECAUSE WE DID NOT HAVE REMEMBER
PRESENT WHEN THEY WERE
PRESENTED.
OR WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM SO
WE'LL GO OVER THOSE BILLS NOW.
OKAY.
OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR HASN'T
PASSED ALREADY WE'RE MOVING TO A
BILLS I WILL TAKE AND SIGNED AN
ORDER.
SO ITEM NUMBER TWO OUT.
ITEM NUMBER ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN BY MISTER
RODRIGUEZ.
WE NEED A MOTION.
SECOND.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
THE MOTION IS.
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO APPROPRIATIONS
CABALLERO O'DONNELL AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WEBER AYE WEBER
AYE.
SIX ZERO SIX ZERO THAT IS OUT. I
WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE ABC EIGHTEEN SIXTY
ONE MY MISTER RODRIGUEZ THE
MOTION IS. TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS WAS CULTURAL OR
WE NEED A WIN EMOTION.
SO.
AMERICAN BY MISTER KALRA AND
SECOND I DUCKED WEBER.
SO IS FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE.
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
O'DONNELL PIE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY. THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WEBER AYE WEBER BY.
SIXTY.
WITH HAS EXERTED BILLS OUT NOW
MOVED TO.
FILE ITEM.
EIGHTEEN.
S. A. B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN TWO BY
MR MEDINA THE MOTION ON FILE
ITEM EIGHTEEN IS.
DO PASSED WITH THEM AND THAT'S
TO APPROPRIATE TO PASS WITH A
MINISTRY APPROPRIATIONS ALL OF
THAT HAS BEEN MOVED BY.
MR THURMAN SECONDED BY I'M
DOCTOR WEBER.
IT'S CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION AGAIN IS TO PASS.
IF THAT NUMBER ON THE FILE
NUMBER FOR THE MOTION THAT WOULD
MOTION IS.
IT PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO
APPROPRIATIONS RIGHT THAT'S FINE
OVER EIGHTEEN AGAIN EIGHTEEN.
O'DONNELL GUY O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
I THEY KNOW LACKEY. LACKEY NO
KALRA. KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
THURMOND. THURMOND AYE WEBER AYE
WEBER AYE.
AND IT IS A FORM FOURTEEN.
I'M SORRY.
FOR TWO PORTER TO TWO FOUR TO
THE BILL'S OUT THAT'S WHY I'M
EIGHTEEN.
YEAH. YEAH.
AND FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN YEAR
VOTERS CHANGED.
OKAY WILL NOW MOVE TO.
FILE ITEM NINETEEN HOLD ON A
MOTION THERE.
SO IS OUR MOTION THERE.
WHICH WAS.
THIS IS A RENDON THEM. I OF THE
BILL.
IF IT'S BEEN MOVED.
I DON'T HEAR SECOND ON THAT.
IT'S MOVED AND SECONDED.
.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS NO THAT'S
ON FILE ITEM.
NINETEEN.
O'DONNELL NO BUT I DON'T KNOW
KILEY. KILEY AYE LACKEY. LACKEY
AYE KALRA.
KALRA NOT VOTING.
MCCARTY. THURMOND.
THIRD THE THURMAN NOT VOTING
WEBER.
VOTING WEBER NOT VOTING IN.
WITH MANY PLEASE GREAT
RECONSIDERATION.
THERE.
YEAH YOU HAVE TO CHANGE I'LL
CHANGE MY VOTE FOR NOTED NOT
VOTED.
RECONSIDERATION.
LOOKING OVER US ALL SCRATCHED.
THE BILL FAILS.
OKAY
THE BILL FAILED.
YEAH CORRECT YES AND YES THE
BUILDING FELL THE NOT HAVE
ENOUGH VOTES AB I NUMBER LITTLE
FIVE FIVE AND NUMBER TWENTY ONE
BY MISTER SANTIAGO AB THREE ZERO
FOUR TWO.
AND THE MOTION ON THAT IS DUE
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO
APPROPRIATE TO PASS WITH AMOUNTS
TO APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY ONE.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
MR THURMAN.
SECOND
SEC MY DOCTOR WEBER PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. O'DONNELL AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY. KILEY NO
LACKEY.
LACKEY NO KALRA. KALRA I.
MCCARTY. THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
I THINK AFFORD WITH TEASED.
IN THE WORDS ARE COMMITTEE BILL
SO NOW WE. KNOW WAS NOT HAD.
NTTA. AMALGAM OF.
I STILL HAVE TO ADD ON TO GET.
YOU HAVE TO DO THAT.
SOME ARE NOT OPEN GAP.
AS WITH MAYOR DROUGHT FOUND.
THIS EDUCATION COMMITTEE MEETING
IS ADJOURNED